I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everyone.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是好闺蜜。现在，我们专门为你带来了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。
Hey, guys. What's up, Ange? What's up with you and your cute pants? Thank you for saying that. I noticed them right away. Here's the thing. I hit a wall with sweatpants. What?
嘿，伙计们。怎么了，安吉？你和你那条可爱的裤子怎么回事？谢谢你这么说。我一眼就注意到了。是这样的。我穿运动裤遇到了瓶颈。什么？
I know. Guys, one of the reasons we started this podcast was because I wanted a job I could do in sweatpants. Uh-huh. You know, we talked about that a lot early on. Yeah. Well, I counted after 409 days of wearing sweatpants. I mean, not every single day, but for the most part for the last 409 days, I would get out of bed and put on sweatpants. Right.
我知道。伙计们，我们开办这个播客的原因之一，就是因为我想要一份可以穿着运动裤干的工作。嗯哼。你知道，我们早期经常讨论这个。是啊。嗯，我数过了，在穿了409天运动裤之后。我是说，不是每天都这样，但在过去的409天里，基本上我都是一起床就穿上运动裤。没错。
I actually had several pairs of pants that were made of the same material as my sheets. Like a jersey. They're a bamboo. Okay. Made by the same company that makes my sheets. Listen, if I could have pants made by people that make bedding. That's what I thought. It's like I'm just wearing my bed around all day.
我其实有好几条裤子，面料跟我床单的一模一样。像泽西面料。是竹纤维的。好吧。跟我床单是同一家公司生产的。听着，如果我能买到由做床品的厂商生产的裤子。我就是这么想的。感觉我整天就像把床穿在身上一样。
I thought I'd hit the jackpot. Okay. So after 409 days of this, I hit a wall and I was like, I need to wear pants, actual pants. So I went out and I bought a pair of pants, Angela. I'm going to stand up. I'm going to show you. I'm going to describe them to you. I'm going to take a picture.
我觉得自己中了头彩。好吧。所以在这样过了409天之后，我遇到了瓶颈，我想，我得穿裤子，真正的裤子。所以我出门买了一条裤子，安吉拉。我要站起来。我要给你看。我要向你描述一下。我要拍张照片。
They kind of look like camouflage, but like very sassy cargo kind of pants. Yeah. That's what I was going for. Sassy cargo? Yeah. I love a sassy cargo. Okay. All right.
它们看起来有点像迷彩裤，但又像是那种非常时髦的工装裤。对。这就是我想要的风格。时髦工装裤？对。我很喜欢时髦工装裤。好吧。好吧。
So here's the thing. I'm wearing sweatpants. I'm in the dressing room and I don't know which size of pants to buy because you've been wearing the baggy britches. That's right. I went back and forth and back and forth and I went with the bigger size. And now I've been wearing them for what? I don't know.
所以情况是这样的。我穿着运动裤。我在试衣间里，不知道该买哪个尺码的裤子，因为你一直穿着宽松肥大的裤子。没错。我试了又试，纠结来纠结去，最后选了大一号的。然后我现在穿了多久？我不知道。
An hour. Uh-huh. Now they're all stretched out. They're too big. And look what happens. Now they're falling down and I've got long crotch. Long crotch, lady. Oh, I see it.
一个小时。嗯哼。现在它们都撑大了。太大了。你看发生什么了。现在它们在往下掉，我的裤裆变长了。长裤裆，女士。哦，我看到了。
You have long crotch. Gals, you know what we're talking about. When like the seam of your pants is like halfway between your thigh and your knees, that's long crotch. So what do I do? I've worn them. I can't take them back and get the smaller size. I think I could get someone to alter it in the back.
你的裤裆变长了。姑娘们，你们懂我们在说什么。就像裤缝在你的大腿和膝盖之间卡了一半，这就是长裤裆。那我该怎么办？我已经穿过了。我不能退货换小号的。我想我可以找人在后面改一下。
Oh, my mom could do that in two seconds. I know. And the thing is, is I just, I'm trying to re-enter. You're trying to re-enter the world. You know, I like the sassy cargo minus the long crotch. What are we doing today? All right. Let me tell you.
哦，我妈妈两秒钟就能搞定。我知道。问题是，我只是，我在试着重新融入。你在试着重新融入世界。你知道，我喜欢时髦工装裤，除了长裤裆。我们今天要做什么？好吧。我来告诉你。
You guys wanting to know what we're doing today. It is business ethics season five episode three. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. It is written by Ryan Coe and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Love it. Here is a summary. Jim reluctantly reveals him and Pam's engagement to the office.
你们想知道我们今天要做什么。那是第五季第三集《商业道德》。哦，耶。嗯哼。本集由瑞恩·科（Ryan Coe）编剧，杰弗里·布里茨（Jeffrey Blitz）执导。太棒了。以下是剧情梗概。吉姆很不情愿地向办公室透露了他和帕姆订婚的消息。
Mm-hmm. We'll discuss. Following Ryan's recent actions, corporate has required Holly to conduct a seminar on business ethics. Michael offers immunity to anyone willing to confess to dishonesty at work. What, are we like an episode of Survivor? I know. You get immunity.
嗯哼。我们会讨论的。由于瑞恩最近的行为，总公司要求霍莉开展一场关于商业道德的讲座。迈克尔向任何愿意承认在工作中有不诚实行为的人提供豁免权。怎么，我们是在拍《幸存者》吗？我知道。你获得了豁免权。
Everything you say. And then we're going to light the torch for you. Well, some things are revealed. Again, we will discuss. And it's going to cause a rift between Michael and Holly. Yeah. Meanwhile, Jim makes Dwight observe the company's time theft policy and Meredith provides outback house takeout to the entire office.
你说的所有话。然后我们要为你点燃火炬。好吧，有些事情被揭露了。同样，我们会进行讨论。这将在迈克尔和霍莉之间造成一条裂痕。是啊。与此同时，吉姆让德怀特遵守公司的防偷懒政策，梅雷迪思为整个办公室提供了澳拜客牛排的外卖。
So that's our summary. Would you like fast fact number one? I really would. All right. New writer alert. Oh. Writer Ryan Coe has joined the staff for season five. Hello, Ryan.
这就是我们的梗概。想要听第一个趣味事实吗？我真的很想听。好吧。新编剧警报。哦。编剧瑞恩·科加入了第五季的工作人员阵容。你好，瑞恩。
Welcome. Hello, Ryan. He was only with us for one season as he left to work on Cougar Town. Oh, we knew lots of folks on Cougar Town. Now, did busy Phillips. Oh, yeah. There's also a writer and co-executive producer of the Simpsons. Welcome, Ryan.
欢迎。你好，瑞恩。他只和我们合作了一季，就离开去参与《熟女镇》的工作了。哦，我们认识《熟女镇》里的很多人。现在，还有忙碌的菲利普斯。哦，对了。也是《辛普森一家》的编剧和联合执行制片人。欢迎，瑞恩。
Welcome. Fast fact number two, no Pam. Outside of the cold open where you hear Pam's voice, there is no Pam in this episode. But there was Pam. There was, you guys. There was. I filmed a bunch of scenes at art school and they all got cut out. I know.
欢迎。趣味事实二，没有帕姆。除了你能听到帕姆声音的冷开场外，这一集里没有帕姆。但其实有帕姆。真的有，伙计们。真的有。我在艺术学校拍了一堆戏份，但都被剪掉了。我知道。
I saw in the deleted scenes, there's like three. Well, I'm going to talk about them. Okay. But on Office Ladies, Pam will be inserted into this episode again. She will live again. She will. And also, Jenna, there was an amazing Ryan Kevin runner that got deleted for time. And it's great.
我在删减片段里看到了，大概有三场。好吧，我会谈到它们的。好吧。但在《办公室女士》中，帕姆将再次被剪进这一集里。她将重获新生。她会的。而且，珍娜，还有一个精彩的瑞恩和凯文的支线情节因为时长被删掉了。那真的很棒。
And I'm going to bring that up. You guys, we're bringing it all back today in Business Ethics. Fast fact number three, Amy Ryan. Holly is here today. We interviewed Amy Ryan all about this episode and her time on the office. Let's hear it. Amy Ryan, welcome to Office Ladies. Hi, Office Ladies.
我会把它提出来的。伙计们，我们今天在《商业道德》中把它们全带回来了。趣味事实三，艾米·莱恩。霍莉今天来了。我们采访了艾米·莱恩，聊了聊这一集以及她在《办公室》的时光。让我们听听。艾米·莱恩，欢迎来到《办公室女士》。嗨，《办公室女士》。
I'm so glad to be here and to see your beautiful faces and the interior of your closets. Yeah, I was going to say welcome to our closets. Amy, it's so good to see you. Holly Flax. Oh my gosh. Hollis, we found out your name is Hollis. Is that right? Because it's on your little name placard.
我很高兴来到这里，看到你们美丽的面孔以及你们衣柜的内部。是啊，我本来想说欢迎来到我们的衣柜。艾米，很高兴见到你。霍莉·弗拉克斯。哦天哪。霍莉斯，我们发现你的名字叫霍莉斯。是这样吗？因为在你的小名牌上有写。
Yes. I don't know if I ever knew that. That's a really good tip. Would you have played the character differently? I would have been much more, you know, refined. I feel like Hollis is much more refined. Or maybe I would have had an accent. I don't know.
是的。我不知道我以前知不知道这件事。这是一个非常好的提示。你会把这个角色演得不一样吗？我会更加，你知道的，温文尔雅。我觉得霍莉斯要温文尔雅得多。或者我可能会带点口音。我不知道。
I think if your character had been a Supreme Court judge, you might have gone by Hollis. Yes. But you ended up in HR and so you went with the less formal Holly, maybe. That's correct. Yeah. Yeah. When you run HR, you really want to be more approachable, you know. Yeah.
我想如果你的角色是个最高法院法官，你可能会用霍莉斯这个名字。是的。但你最后去了人力资源部，所以你可能选了不那么正式的霍莉。没错。是这样的。是的。当你负责人力资源时，你真的希望自己更容易接近，你知道的。是的。
Kind of a, you know, warm fuzzy character. That makes sense. Holly was a warm fuzzy character and we're in love with her. I am so enamored by Holly and Michael. Jenna and I have cried because Michael is like finally with someone that cares about him. She's done. Well, in watching it episode by episode and just four years of Michael not having a partner to suddenly see a woman partner with him and joke with him and like his jokes.
有点像那种，你知道的，温暖亲切的角色。这说得通。霍莉是个温暖亲切的角色，我们都深爱着她。我太迷恋霍莉和迈克尔了。珍娜和我曾感动得哭泣，因为迈克尔终于和真正关心他的人在一起了。她受够了。嗯，在一集又一集地观看的过程中，经历了整整四年迈克尔没有伴侣，突然看到一个女人与他结伴，和他开玩笑，还喜欢他的笑话。
I did. I cried. Oh, you know, in preparation for meeting you both today, I rewatched the episode. I hadn't watched the show in a long time. We saved her like popping in the room when my daughter was on her third pass of the series. But it is so moving. I think all the characters are so moving. There's, I know everyone's talked about this before, but that element of the family, you
我真的哭了。哦，你知道的，为了准备今天和你们俩见面，我重温了这一集。我很久没看这部剧了。我们省得她突然闯进房间，当时我女儿正在刷第三遍这部剧。但这真的很感人。我觉得所有的角色都太感人了。我知道每个人以前都讨论过这个，但那种家庭的元素，你
know, it's not a workplace. It's actually a family and that really comes through so beautifully. But Holly and Michael, I mean, I've always said, you know, there's a lid for every pot. So they finally found each other, but she has a high tolerance, I suppose, for, for that kind of guy. Well, we always like to ask people, Amy, how did you come to be on the show? And we did a little research. Paul Lieberstein told us that they came to you.
知道的，这不是一个工作场所。这其实是一个家庭，这一点体现得太美妙了。但霍莉和迈克尔，我的意思是，我一直都说，锅配锅，盖配盖。所以他们终于找到了彼此，但我想她对那种类型的男人有很高的容忍度。好吧，我们总是喜欢问别人，艾米，你是怎么加入这部剧的？我们做了一些研究。保罗·利伯斯坦告诉我们，是他们主动找你的。
They were huge fans, but that you had simultaneously mentioned to your agent, you might like to do our show. Yes. So what was that process? Yeah. How did it go down? That is true. And the timing was eerie because I did say that to my agent.
他们是你的超级粉丝，但你同时也向你的经纪人提到过，你可能想演我们的剧。是的。那么那个过程是怎样的？对。进展如何？那是真的。而且时机非常诡异，因为我的确对我的经纪人说过这话。
It was, it was soon after the Oscars. And I was like, you know, I'm doing a lot of dramas. And if I have any kind of cachet right now at this moment, I want to do a comedy and I want to do a comedy like The Office because I was never good at the four camera sitcom. I just felt too much pressure. And it wasn't like, I always feel like characters weren't really rooted in a reality the way the office was. And that goes back to how I met Paul Lieberstein.
那是，那是奥斯卡颁奖典礼后不久。当时我想，你知道的，我接了很多正剧。如果我现在这个时刻还有点名望的话，我想演喜剧，我想演像《办公室》这样的喜剧，因为我从来不擅长多机位的情景喜剧。我总是感到太大的压力。而且我觉得这些角色不像《办公室》那样真正植根于现实。这就说到了我是怎么认识保罗·利伯斯坦的。
We were both employed on The Naked Truth. And he was a writer. My agent had kind of reached out. And at the same time, Paul had reached out, I guess, to him. I don't know who got there first, but it was, I really think it was like about the same week. And Paul had mentioned that he was also a fan of The Wire as were some of the other writers. So it was kind of a culmination of all those worlds coming together. And did they pitch the character of Holly to you?
我们当时都在《真相大白》剧组工作。他是一名编剧。我的经纪人曾联系过他。与此同时，保罗也联系了对方，我猜是这样。我不知道谁先联系的，但我觉得大概就在同一个星期。保罗曾提到他也是《火线重案组》的粉丝，其他一些编剧也是。所以这可以说是所有这些世界交汇的一个高潮。他们向你推销霍莉这个角色了吗？
Or did you like have a script to read or anything? I don't remember reading a script. I remember saying hearing it was a one episode only and potential love interest, which obviously I knew was code for. We'll see how you do, kid. If we have you back. I remember also because I was a big fan of the British series. David finally gets a woman who likes him too.
还是说你读了剧本之类的？我不记得读过剧本。我只记得听说这个角色只出现一集，而且是一个潜在的恋爱对象，很显然我知道这其实是暗号。走着瞧吧，孩子。看我们以后还用不用你。我还记得，因为我是英国原版剧集的超级粉丝。大卫终于找到了一个也喜欢他的女人。
So it was loosely based, I think, on her for the first episode. And then our group took it to a different level. So there was no script that I was pretty to, but I knew the kind of general idea of it. What was it like to walk on to the set for the first time? Really weird. It's really weird. It's also then a now I'm a fan of the American version. And you start to know the set obviously from the comfort of your couch or your tablet or whatever it is.
所以第一集的内容我想大致是根据她改编的。然后我们的团队把它提升到了一个不同的水平。所以我没有看到任何剧本，但我大致知道它的整体构思。第一次走进片场是什么感觉？真的很诡异。真的很诡异。而且这也是一个“现在我是美国版粉丝”的心态。你显然开始从沙发、平板电脑或任何设备的舒适环境中熟悉这个片场。
You know, when you get there, it's like, oh, everything's smaller. And then there you all were so warm and welcoming. You know, there's always an element of being the new kid in school and how's that going to go down. But and also you guys at this point are on a really massive, you know, big hit show. And it was the most down to earth welcoming warm group of people like true ensemble that I met. And even to the end, I feel like, you know, you hear all those stories of shows that become so successful. The bad behavior starts coming out and, you know, but at least I didn't see any of that. And I just thought it was always about the work and you guys really set such a beautiful tone there.
你知道的，当你到了那里，就会觉得，哦，所有东西都更小了。然后你们所有人都那么热情和欢迎。你知道的，作为学校里的新转学生总有一种未知感，不知道会怎么样。而且在这个时候，你们已经是一部非常宏大、非常热门的剧集了。这里是我见过的最脚踏实地、最热情温暖的一群人，真正的集体。甚至直到最后，我觉得，你知道的，你听过所有那些关于剧集变得如此成功的故事。开始出现不良行为，你知道的，但至少我没有看到任何那种现象。我只觉得一切都是为了工作，你们真的在那里定下了一个非常美好的基调。
Well, you said you rewatched business ethics. And one of my favorite parts is when you and Michael do the let's get physical. Yes, that's so funny. I watched that with my daughter and we watched that scene like two times in a row just him reaching in trying to hit the play button. And then the two of you running in with those headbands and your dance number. How did you guys come up with all that? What do we do? Well, I get the headbands.
好吧，你说你重温了《商业道德》。我最喜欢的片段之一就是你和迈克尔跳“Let's get physical”那段。是的，太搞笑了。我和我女儿一起看了那个片段，我们连着看了两遍他伸手去按播放键的那一幕。然后你们两个戴着发带跑进来跳舞。你们是怎么想出这一切的？我们是怎么做的？好吧，发带归我。
I have to give credit for wardrobe. I mean, that was pretty wonderful and ridiculous. Just that having that visual, the dance, honestly, that's me just following Steve. I anything, you know, I always anything that I was lucky enough to be partnered paired with Steve, I was smart enough to get in the sidecar of that motorcycle ride. I'm not going to leave this here. He's going to have a better idea. So that was that was just me kind of, you know, follow.
我得称赞一下服装部门。我的意思是，那真的很棒又很荒谬。光是那种视觉效果、舞蹈，老实说，那就是我跟着史蒂夫学。无论什么，你知道的，我总是，只要我有幸能和史蒂夫搭档，我都足够聪明，懂得坐上他摩托车旅行的边三轮。我才不会自己单干呢。他总会有更好的点子。所以那，那其实就是我，你知道的，跟着。
Yeah, literally following his choreography. Well, I wasn't there because my character was at art school. So I am super bummed that I did not get to see that done live. Did you guys do like tons of takes of it? You were there and do you guys remember? It was so hard not to laugh like from the minute it started. And when I was rewatching it, Oscar's face says it all. He's in the front and I was like, I don't want to be in the front.
是的，字面意思上跟着他的编排。好吧，我当时不在，因为我的角色在艺术学校。所以我超级遗憾没能亲眼看到现场拍摄。你们当时拍了很多条吗？你在现场，你们还记得吗？从开始的那一分钟起，就很难忍住不笑。当我重温这一集时，奥斯卡的表情说明了一切。他在前排，当时我想，我可不想坐在前排。
Please don't put me in the front because I knew I was going to get so tickled. And Oscar does this thing when he's trying not to break. You know, we know each other's tails after all those years where he kind of does this mouth open thing. And that's him trying not to laugh. So you go back and watch Oscar's like, I'm going to. It was so funny. First of all, being in that conference, you know, that's kind of the most famous part of the set, right? Here we go.
千万别把我安排在前排，因为我知道我会笑得肚子疼。奥斯卡在努力憋笑时会做一件事。历经那些年，我们对彼此的小动作都心知肚明，他会做这种张着嘴的表情。那就是他在努力不笑。所以你回去看奥斯卡就会发现，他一副“我要……”的表情。太搞笑了。首先，身处那个会议室里，你知道的，那是片场最有名的部分，对吧？我们开始吧。
And someone gets to present something and it's better when, again, you're paired with someone next to you. But those scenes where I'm alone giving the conference, my hands are like white knuckle. I'm like trying to be like, you know, very casual holding my hands. But if you look closely, my hands are just like two iron fists of nerves. That's the other thing like the everyone always asks me is the office. Was that a lot of improv? And I said, no, it was. I remember scripty coming up to me, you know, correcting me for like of instead of act, like something really tiny.
有人要作报告，而且正如我所说，当你和旁边的人搭档时，效果会更好。但那些我自己做报告的场景，我的手都抓得关节发白。我试图让自己看起来，你知道的，非常随意地放着手。但如果你仔细看，我的手就像由于紧张而攥成的两只铁拳。还有一件事，每个人总是问我关于《办公室》的问题是：那是即兴发挥吗？我说，不，不是的。我记得剧本统筹走到我跟前，你知道的，纠正我的一些小词，比如把某个词换成另一个，非常细微的改动。
And I tell people and tell me if I'm wrong. I was like, it was heavily scripted. And then maybe by the third take, Steve would go off script first and then everyone would follow suit. That's my recollection of it. Did you say that's right? Absolutely. Yeah. And then and in that, I just think it was again, like, you guys are so in tune with each other and no one trying to beat anyone to the punchline.
我告诉别人，如果我说错了请纠正我。我说过：那是严格按照剧本演的。然后大概到了第三条，史蒂夫会率先脱离剧本，然后大家就会纷纷效仿。这是我的记忆。你觉得对吗？完全正确。是的。然后，在那个过程中，我只是觉得，你们对彼此太有默契了，没有人试图去抢别人的包袱。
It was just a constant setup. I thought it was just so perfect. And I think that's why people can't really tell between the scripted and when it goes to improv. It was just so, just so perfectly done. I wanted to ask you about those restaurant scenes. Oh, yeah. Coopers. There's that whole runner about the Chastity Belt where he's trying to explain what a Chastity Belt is.
这完全是一个持续的配合。我觉得简直完美无缺。我想这也是为什么人们很难分辨哪些是按剧本演的，哪些是即兴发挥。真的是做得，做得太完美了。我想问你关于那些餐厅场景的事。哦，对。库珀斯餐厅。那里有一整段关于贞操带的支线，他在努力解释什么是贞操带。
Oh, my God. And you are like a Chastity Belt. I think like the really fun part of their relationship is that it's always a surprise when like Holly's on board with him with some joke. And then those moments like the Chastity Belt where she's so horrified and yet so forgiving. You know, here she is this, you know, she's still flirty with this guy and she likes him and not sure where it's going to go. But she's going to give that a pass. You know, always with Steve, it was so hard not to laugh. It was also like a thrill that sets in.
哦，天哪。而你就像是：贞操带？我觉得他们关系中最有趣的部分是，当霍莉对他的某个笑话表示赞同并加入时，总是充满了惊喜。然后像贞操带那样，她感到既震惊又极其包容的时刻。你知道的，在这里她依然，你知道的，她还在对这个家伙调情，她喜欢他，也不确定事情会发展到哪一步。但她会放他一马。你知道的，和史蒂夫在一起时，总是很难不笑。那也带有一种随之而来的刺激感。
Look, I remember when I was 25, I went skydiving and I did it where you're strapped to the other instructor. And just as the airplane door opened up and he made me look out, we were about, I guess, 13,000 feet near. And I remember the thought in my head is, okay, I'm going to die or I'm going to have the time of my life, pick one. And I remember picking, I'm going to have fun. And as nervous as I was, you know, being like in those scenes with Steve, I remember that moment too like, oh, just pick one. Why don't you have fun instead? And certainly with him at the lead, like, we're all going to look good, you know, he's going to take us along for the ride, I feel. But it was so hard not to laugh, like painfully hard not to laugh at him.
看，我记得在我25岁的时候，我去玩了高空跳伞，我是和一个教练绑在一起跳的。就在飞机门打开的那一刻，他让我往下看，我们当时大概，我猜离地有13,000英尺。我记得我脑子里的想法是，好吧，我要么会死，要么会度过我生命中最美好的时光，二选一。我记得我选了，我要去享受乐趣。尽管我很紧张，你知道的，和史蒂夫一起拍那些戏时，我也记得那个时刻，就像：哦，选一个吧。你为什么不去找点乐子呢？当然了，有他带头，我们都会表现得很好，你知道的，我觉得他会带着我们一起经历这段旅程。但真的很难不笑，痛苦地很难不笑出来。
But I felt like we're dropped into another place of concentration that kind of pulled it all along, if that makes sense. Yeah, did you know Steve before? Yeah, you know, in a very, I had this miniscule part in Dan and Real Life that Steve starred in. It was this big extended family comedy. We all as a whole group of us there on location in Rhode Island. And so we all became friends. And then I think it was about like six months after that film is when the office came up. And I believe they ran the idea by Steve of casting me and I guess it helped. I knew him from Rhode Island for that little bit.
但我感觉我们被带入了另一种专注的境界，把这一切都支撑下去了，如果这说得通的话。是的，你之前认识史蒂夫吗？对，你知道的，在一个非常，我在史蒂夫主演的电影《老爸 S.O.S.》里有一个极小的角色。这是一部关于大家庭的喜剧。我们在罗德岛的外景地作为一大群人聚在一起。所以我们都成了朋友。然后我想大概是在那部电影上映六个月后，《办公室》就出现了。我相信他们曾向史蒂夫提出过由我来演的想法，我想我之前在罗德岛和他短暂共事过这件事帮了忙。
Well, we always ask everyone if they have any like favorite memories from their time on the show, like any kind of behind the scenes moment or just something that you remember that stood out to you during your time on the office. Oh my gosh, there's so so much. I mean, just just in a general note, I would honestly not no exaggeration. I would go home feeling like I worked out a series of sit ups because my stomach muscles were always in play for laughing so hard. And I just go home exhausted but happy. And that was a nice feeling. And speaking of that, like kind of the uncontrollable laughter, there's the episode where Darryl helps me move and he comes in the car ride, the truck ride. He has, yeah.
好吧，我们总是问每个人，他们是否有任何来自剧组的最爱记忆，比如任何幕后时刻，或者在《办公室》期间对你触动很深的事情。哦天哪，有太多太多了。我的意思是，仅就总体感受而言，我真的毫不夸张地说。我回家时会觉得，自己刚做完了一系列仰卧起坐，因为我笑得太厉害，腹肌一直在用力。我总是精疲力竭但又很高兴地回家。那是一种美妙的感觉。说到这个，那种无法控制的笑声，有一集是达里尔帮我搬家，他坐上了车，那辆卡车。他有，是的。
Me, Steve and Craig like hold up in that truck all day kind of probably we had a little bit of lack of oxygen, but we couldn't we just we were in hysterics and could barely get through the scenes. And it was that that was like one of the highlights of my time there was just spending the day with those two guys. Just laughing. I mean, I say that but I'd also be on set and laughing all the time too. It was just very new to me. Usually end up in these dramas where I'm crying all day. So this is a much better way to spend your day. I remember that too and I remember my agents asking me if I wanted to do dramas in my downtime.
我和史蒂夫还有克雷格一整天都闷在那辆卡车里，可能我们当时都有点缺氧，但我们停不下来，我们歇斯底里地大笑，几乎无法完成拍摄。那是，那是我的高光时刻之一，就是在那里跟那两个家伙度过了一整天。一直在笑。我的意思是，我这么说，但我在片场时也总是笑个不停。这对我很新奇。我通常演的都是那些让我哭一整天的正剧。所以这是一种度过一整天的好得多的方式。我也记得那个，我还记得我的经纪人问我，在空闲时间是否想演正剧。
You mentioned you were like I've done a lot of dramas. I want to do a comedy. Do you want to take a stab at some drama? And I was like, I don't think so. I'm really liking the jobs where I just laugh all day because I'm like in a good mood a lot. So let's just let's keep doing the comedies. It was like it was a happy place to work. My only request was if I could ever have a scene where I didn't frown.
你提到过，你当时想：我演了很多正剧。我想演喜剧。你想不想尝试一下正剧？而我说，我才不要。我很喜欢那些让我整天笑口常开的工作，因为我经常心情很好。所以让我们，让我们继续演喜剧吧。那是一个工作起来很开心的地方。我唯一的请求是，能不能给我安排一场不用皱眉的戏。
That's true. You had to frown your way through this comedy. Well, do you get recognized as Holly Flax like when you're out and about? Oh, I do. I do. And it's interesting. I'm sure I'm sure you guys have noticed that there's been being recognized when the show was on the air and then the whole streaming. The version of the show that has kind of taken it to a whole new level and everyone's getting younger.
没错。在这部喜剧里你得一路皱着眉演下来。好吧，当你外出时，会被认出是霍莉·弗拉克斯吗？哦，会的。会的。很有意思。我确信，我确信你们也注意到了，当剧集在电视上热播时有人认出你，然后就是整个流媒体时代。这种将剧集带到一个全新高度的播放模式，让观众群体变得越来越年轻。
My daughter's friends. So yeah, I do. I still get recognized. You know, years ago, not that long ago, a few years ago, my family and our really good friends, we went to Scranton because there's this amazing antique store called Old Good Things and it's just a warehouse, a giant warehouse of just every old antique knob, hinge, dresser, door, toilet. Sign me up. It goes on forever. It's really cool.
我女儿的朋友们。所以，是的，会。我还是会被认出来。几年前，其实没那么久，几年前，我和我的家人还有好朋友们，我们去了斯克兰顿，因为那里有一家非常棒的古董店叫“美好旧物”，它只是一个仓库，一个巨大的仓库，里面塞满了各种旧古董旋钮、合页、梳妆台、门、马桶。算我一个。它一眼望不到头。真的很酷。
And so we go there and then we're looking for something to eat. We're hungry and they pull in and I was kind of behind the eight ball on this and we pull into Cooper's. Oh my gosh. And I go, oh, no, no, no, you guys know, I'm pretty, I mean, I don't get harassed being, you know, but I, I'm pretty shy. If someone comes up to me on the street, I say hello and thank you. But but I also have a lot of privacy. People don't always recognize me, but I was like, hell no, we are not going into Cooper's. I am probably from the office.
所以我们去了那里，然后我们在找吃的。我们饿了，他们把车开进去，我当时在这件事上有点后知后觉，我们把车开进了库珀斯餐厅。哦，天哪。我说，哦，不，不，不，你们知道的，我很，我的意思是，我不会因为我是，你知道的，遭到骚扰，但我，我其实很害羞。如果有人在大街上走过来找我，我会打招呼并说谢谢。但同时我也注重隐私。人们并不总能认出我，但我当时想：见鬼去吧，我们绝不能进库珀斯。我可能是《办公室》里的人。
I cannot walk into Cooper's. I cannot. I cannot. And my one friend and was there, she's kind of naughty, she's like, oh, it'll be so good. We have to, we have to. So they talk me into it, but I go in and I've got my head down and I'm just like waiting. I'm waiting to be treated, you know, like the Beatles here or something. And we, we sit in a booth and this old tired waitress comes up and she takes our order and my friend and right away, she's like, this is amazing.
我不能走进库珀斯。我不能。我真的不能。我的一位朋友也在那儿，她有点淘气，她说，哦，这会很有趣的。我们得去，我们必须去。于是他们说服了我，但我走进去时一直低着头，我只是在等待。我在等待受到像甲壳虫乐队那样的待遇或者别的什么。我们，我们坐在一个卡座里，一个面容疲惫的老服务员走过来点单，我的朋友立刻就说，这太棒了。
You know, what, what's the story here? Well, we've been here for X amount of years and it was also used in the set of the office. But you know, I mean, people used to be excited about that, but they're not anymore. What can I get you? So offended. Not one person recognized me. I know I'm not one, not one. And we left.
你知道的，这里的历史是怎样的？哦，我们在这里开了好多年了，这里也曾是《办公室》的取景地。但你知道的，人们以前会为此感到兴奋，但现在不了。你们想点点什么？好受打击。竟然没有一个人认出我。我知道我不是，一个都没有，一个都没有。然后我们就走了。
We gave her a good tip and we left and I was like so, so bummed. Anyway, that's my Cooper story. It's pretty cool inside though. I think our set decoration did a pretty great job. The real Cooper's is pretty cool. Yeah. Well, when people hear this podcast and they realize they might have been at Cooper's with Holly Flacks and didn't know it. They're going to be like, what day, what day?
我们给了她小费然后离开了，当时我感到超级、超级沮丧。不管怎样，这就是我的库珀斯故事。不过里面其实挺酷的。我觉得我们的布景设计做得很棒。现实中的库珀斯确实挺酷的。是的。好吧，当人们听到这个播客，意识到他们可能曾经和霍莉·弗拉克斯一起在库珀斯吃饭却浑然不知时。他们会问：哪一天，到底是哪一天？
Oh my God. It's part of like a whole Scranton the office fan tour now. You know, they have, they have like a whole tour and you can go around Scranton and go to all the spots. Oh my God. So maybe, maybe don't go back because maybe it will be the Beatles experience. Amy, before you were going to come on the podcast, I admit I Googled you, which is a weird thing to do. It's weird to Google someone you know. It is.
哦，天哪。现在它已经成了斯克兰顿《办公室》粉丝全套观光之旅的一部分了。你知道的，他们有，他们有一整条旅游路线，你可以绕着斯克兰顿参观所有的拍摄地。哦，天哪。所以也许，也许不要再去了，因为说不定下次就会有甲壳虫乐队般的体验了。艾米，在你来上播客之前，我承认我谷歌搜索了你，虽然对你认识的人进行谷歌搜索是件很奇怪的事。对认识的人进行谷歌搜索是挺奇怪的。确实是。
It's so weird. And I, you know, had never done that before Googled you, but I did. And I saw all of your stage work and stage experience, which I, I knew that you did theater, but I didn't know that you got your first touring job right out of school that you toured with Biloxi Blues right out of high school. Yeah. So did you ever have like that day job? Did you ever have or were you able to work pretty consistently as an actress right out of school? Yeah.
太不可思议了。你知道，我以前从没做过那种事——去谷歌搜你，但我确实这么做了。我看到了你所有的舞台作品和舞台经验，我——我知道你演过话剧，但我不知道你一毕业就得到了第一份巡演工作，你在高中刚毕业时就跟着《比洛克西蓝调》去巡演了。是的。所以你有没有过那种普通的工作？你有没有过，或者说你一毕业就能作为女演员相当稳定地工作？是的。
So I went to a performing arts high school in New York and then a month or so after graduation, I was cast in the touring company of Biloxi Blues. And I toured for nine months and thought, well, that's easy. I'll work all the time, I guess. I didn't work for a long time afterwards, but, but I, after the tour, you know, I was still only like 18, 19. So, you know, I went back home. I didn't have rent. I was still, you know, my family, we lived in New York. So I was able to afford a life in New York by just being an actor and doing acting jobs until I moved out of the house in my mid 30s.
所以我去了纽约的一所表演艺术高中，然后在毕业大约一个月后，我被选中加入了《比洛克西蓝调》的巡演剧团。我巡演了九个月，心想，嗯，这挺容易的。我想我会一直有工作吧。此后很长一段时间我都没有工作，但是，但是，巡演结束后，你知道，我当时也才18、19岁左右。所以，你知道，我回了家。我不用付房租。我当时还是，你知道，我的家人，我们住在纽约。所以我能够通过只做一名演员和表演工作来负担在纽约的生活，直到我在30多岁时搬出家门。
I know. But I know, yeah, I'm very, I'm very lucky. I had, I've only ever been an actor, saved before high school graduation, I worked at my aunt and uncle's ice cream shop in Vermont when I was 16. But yeah, acting's been my only job. That's amazing. It's kind of weird. But I, you know, I do think of how any young actor, artist moves to LA, moves to New York from other places or, you know, to Chicago with. I always think of that person like suitcase in hand and, you know, room share list.
我知道。但我知道，是的，我非常，我非常幸运。我从来只当过演员，高中毕业前除外，我16岁时在佛蒙特州我阿姨和叔叔的冰淇淋店工作过。但是，是的，表演一直是我唯一的工作。太棒了。这有点奇怪。不过我，你知道，我确实在想任何年轻演员、艺术家是如何搬到洛杉矶，从其他地方搬到纽约，或者，你知道，带着……去芝加哥的。我总是想到那种人，手提行李箱，还有，你知道的，合租名单。
Like my hack just goes off to them because it's so hard. It's so hard. I don't know how people do it. You know, I was lucky that I already lived in New York and could go home for home cooked meals and all that kind of stuff. But, but I'm glad they're doing it somehow. Are you working on anything now, Amy? I just finished this new first season of this Hulu series called Only Murders in the Building with Steve Martin and Martin Short and Selena Gomez. And it was again, like it was, it was a throwback to like, again, Jenna, like you say, like doing the comedy like, oh, this feels fun.
就像我向他们致以最崇高的敬意一样，因为这太难了。这太难了。我不知道人们是怎么做到的。你知道，我很幸运，我本来就住在纽约，可以回家吃家常饭菜以及所有诸如此类的事情。但是，很高兴他们不管怎样都在坚持。艾米，你现在在做什么吗？我刚刚拍完Hulu这部新剧的第一季，叫《公寓大楼里的谋杀案》，主演是史蒂夫·马丁、马丁·肖特和赛琳娜·戈麦斯。这又是一次，就像是一次复古之旅，珍娜，正如你所说，就像演喜剧一样，哦，这感觉真有趣。
I'm in a good mood. And certainly shooting through a pandemic, you know, it was, I wouldn't want to be on a heavy drama right now. It's just too intense, but it was, it was a joy to be around those people during this time. And so, but that's it. And I don't know. I don't know what I'll do next that, you know, even after 33 years, like I never know what's next. So let's see what happens. Well, Amy, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies and sharing your memories of being on the show.
我心情很好。当然，在疫情期间拍戏，你知道的，我现在可不想拍那种沉重的剧情片。那太强烈了，但在这种时期能和那些人在一起真是一种快乐。所以，事情就是这样。而且我不知道。我不知道接下来我会做什么，你知道，甚至在33年之后，我还是从来不知道接下来会发生什么。让我们看看会发生什么吧。好吧，艾米，非常感谢你来到“办公室女士”播客，分享你在剧组的美好回忆。
It was so cool to be back in touch with you and see you again. I'll say here, I really miss you guys and I hope all's well with your families and hope to see you in person. Yes. That would be amazing. Jenna and I have said we want to do like a, like an Office Ladies lunch, like call up all the guys. Have a lunch. Wouldn't that be so fun? Yeah.
能重新联系上你并再次见到你真是太棒了。我在这里说，我真的很想念你们，希望你们的家人一切都好，也希望能在现实中见到你们。是的。那太棒了。珍娜和我曾说过，我们想搞一次，就像是一次“办公室女士”午餐会，把所有人都叫上。吃个午餐。那不是很有趣吗？是的。
Oh, gosh. Well, let's do it. Let's do it. Thank you so much, Amy. Thanks for having me on your show and miss you all and let's hope to see you soon. That was so great. I love her. I love her.
哦，天哪。好吧，我们办吧。我们办吧。非常感谢你，艾米。谢谢你邀请我上你的节目，想念你们所有人，希望我们很快能再见。太棒了。我太喜欢她了。我太喜欢她了。
You know, when we got finished with that interview, you guys, I asked her what color were her walls, because her room, it was like painted all this like kind of dark blue gray color. Kind of a navy blue. It's very cozy looking. I know. And she's in a red dress and her hair was perfect. I kind of want to get that bob. I don't know if I can pull it off.
你知道，采访结束的时候，伙计们，我问她墙壁是什么颜色的，因为她的房间，被刷成了那种有点暗的蓝灰色。有点像海军蓝。看起来非常温馨。我知道。她穿着一件红裙子，头发完美无瑕。我有点想剪那个波波头。我不知道我能不能驾驭得了。
It was such a cute bob. It was. Well, you know, obviously we're going to put photos from our zoomie zoom and the Instagram. Yeah. So you can see it all the wall, the bob, it's coming at you. Okay. Before we get into this episode, I need to share with you who was on the DVD commentary. Oh, but I'm going to let BJ tell you.
那是个非常可爱的波波头。确实是。好吧，你知道的，我们显然会把我们Zoom连线和Instagram上的照片放上去。是的。所以你可以看到所有的细节，墙壁，波波头，它们正向你走来。好了。在我们进入这一集之前，我需要与大家分享是谁录制了DVD评论音轨。哦，不过我要让BJ来告诉你们。
Welcome to the commentary on business ethics. This is BJ Novak speaking, and this is a very special commentary because I have with me here four of the most beloved crew members on the office to give us a behind the scenes look at how things go. Not just with this episode, but every day for the past hundred episodes. So seated with me. Why don't we make introductions from my left? What are you doing?
欢迎收听关于商业道德的评论音轨。我是BJ·诺瓦克，这是一期非常特殊的评论音轨，因为我身边有四位《办公室》里最受喜爱的剧组工作人员，来带我们一探幕后情况。不仅是这一集，还有过去一百集的每一天。所以和我坐在一起。我们从我的左边开始做个自我介绍吧？你在干什么？
Peter Evangelatos. Sergio Zucumen. Alan Mork. And here's how it works. There are. I know. Oh my God. I know.
彼得·埃万杰拉托斯。塞尔吉奥·苏库曼。阿兰·莫克。事情是这样的。有。我知道。噢，天哪。我知道。
I know. I had the same reaction. And their voices are on the whole thing. Yes. Oh my goodness. I did not. I know. I know.
我知道。我有同样的反应。而且整段里面都有他们的声音。是的。噢，天哪。我没有。我知道。我知道。
I texted BJ. I said, BJ, I have teared up. I have laughed. I have had every emotion. Okay. Okay. We should say who they are. Okay.
我给BJ发了短信。我说，BJ，我都感动得流泪了。我大笑过。我有过各种各样的情绪。好吧。好吧。我们应该说说他们是谁。好吧。
So Peter and Vartan, they did our craft services. They provided the cast and crew with stacks, drinks, meals, anything that you could want and fed us in overtime. We called them the snack masters. Peter was so beloved to us. He was like our grandpa. Yeah. And he took such good care of us.
所以彼得和瓦尔坦，他们负责我们的后勤餐饮。他们为演员和剧组提供零食、饮料、正餐，任何你想要的东西，并在我们加班时喂饱我们。我们管他们叫零食大师。彼得对我们来说是如此深受爱戴。他就像我们的爷爷一样。是的。他把我们照顾得无微不至。
He passed away a few years ago. Our cast and crew were heartbroken. We loved this man. And it was a delight to get to hear his voice in this DVD commentary. I felt like I spent, you know, an evening with him when I rewatched it and I texted BJ immediately and he said, oh my God, Angela, where is this? Where can I hear it? Where does it live?
他在几年前去世了。我们的演员和剧组都心碎了。我们深爱着这个人。能在这次DVD评论音轨中听到他的声音真是一种享受。当我重新观看时，我觉得自己仿佛，你知道，和他在一个晚上度过了，我立刻给BJ发了短信，他说，天哪，安吉拉，这是哪里？我在哪里能听到它？它在哪里？
He said, I'm so happy it made you happy. He said, I'm so happy it exists. And he said that he pitched that Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Alan do this commentary and people were like, what? No, you're crazy. But he was like, you know, like they are like our sustenance. They took such good care of us. We should say Sergio and Alan, yes, they were big time catering and they fed us lunch and
他说，我很高兴它能让你快乐。他说，我很高兴它存在。并且他说他曾提议让彼得、瓦尔坦、塞尔吉奥和阿兰来录制这个评论音轨，当时人们的反应是，什么？不，你疯了吧。但他坚持说，你知道的，就像，他们是我们的精神支柱。他们把我们照顾得太好了。我们得说说塞尔吉奥和阿兰，是的，他们是大厨级别的餐饮主管，他们给我们提供午餐和
breakfast. They did our big main meals, yeah, breakfast and lunch and Peter and Vartan did everything in between. Yeah. And I really want to share with you what all they talked about on the DVD commentary. They talked about food the whole entire episode. I learned nothing about the actual episode, but I learned what everyone has for breakfast in people's particular like request and it was so delightful.
早餐。他们负责我们主要的正餐，是的，早餐和午餐，而彼得和瓦尔坦则包办了其他所有事情。是的。我真的很想和你们分享他们在DVD评论音轨里谈论的所有内容。他们整整一集都在谈论食物。我关于实际这一集的内容什么都没学到，但我知道了每个人早餐吃什么以及每个人特别的要求，这太令人愉快了。
And I think the office fans are going to love this. You got to say. Okay. You have to share. Okay. Okay. Here we go. And then I promise we will get to business ethics.
我想《办公室》的粉丝们一定会喜欢这个。你得说说。好吧。你必须分享。好吧。好吧。我们开始吧。然后我向你们保证，我们会讲到商业道德。
You guys. Okay. First of all, we love people's process. How is their day started, what do they do? Sergio and Alan shared that they got to set very, very early. Well, we knew this. I looked up our call sheets. You guys know I have digital clutter.
伙计们。好吧。首先，我们喜欢了解人们的日常流程。他们的一天是怎么开始的，他们都做些什么？塞尔吉奥和阿兰分享说，他们到片场的时间非常非常早。好吧，我们知道这一点。我查了我们的通告单。伙计们，你们知道我有数字杂物。
I have all of our call sheets for years. Yeah. Average cast call time started at 5 a.m. That meant hair and makeup had to be there at 4 a.m. That meant that Sergio and Alan had to have a full breakfast ready at 4 a.m. Wow. And they would go to bed at 7 p.m. and get up between midnight and 1 a.m. to be at work at 2 a.m. to start cooking.
多年来所有的通告单我都留着。是的。平均演员通告时间从早上5点开始。这意味着发型和化妆必须在早上4点到场。这意味着塞尔吉奥和阿兰必须在早上4点准备好丰盛的早餐。哇。他们会在晚上7点睡觉，然后在午夜到凌晨1点之间起床，以便在凌晨2点到达工作地点开始做饭。
Alan said every morning I was cooking bacon at 3 a.m. and they kind of joked that he was like Michael Scott. He like woke up and had to start cooking bacon. But you know, they fed breakfast to around 150 people. Yeah. Because the crew got a hot breakfast. Yeah. Everybody.
阿兰说，每天早上我都在凌晨3点煎培根，他们甚至开玩笑说他就像迈克尔·斯科特。他醒来就得开始煎培根。但你知道的，他们要为大约150人提供早餐。是的。因为剧组人员能吃到热腾腾的早餐。是的。每个人。
Everybody. Cast and crew. Sergio and Alan, like BJ would just mention someone's name and they knew their breakfast order. Okay. Okay. Ready? Yeah.
每个人。演员和剧组。塞尔吉奥和阿兰，就像BJ只要提到某人的名字，他们就知道他们的早餐订单。好吧。好吧。准备好了吗？是的。
Steve would have mushrooms, ground turkey, egg white scramble with a side of ketchup. Okay. Rain would have a veggie scramble with egg whites and one piece of wheat toast. Mmm. Jenna. Yes? Would have two egg whites scrambled with a little bit of cheese. That's true.
史蒂夫会吃蘑菇、碎火鸡肉、蛋白炒蛋，配上一份番茄酱。好吧。雷恩会吃素食炒蛋、蛋白和一片全麦吐司。嗯。珍娜。什么？会吃两个炒蛋白，加一点点奶酪。没错。
Paul Lieberstein would have an egg white scramble with onions and peppers with Sergio's famous homemade salsa on the side. You weren't very into egg whites as a cast, I'm discovering. Oh, it's keep it coming. Kate had egg white scramble with turkey bacon, Oscar, curveball, grilled cheese with tomato, Amy Ryan, who's our guest this week, spinach and egg scramble. Now some cast members had their breakfast order become classics because they became so popular.
保罗·利伯斯坦会吃加了洋葱和彩椒的蛋白炒蛋，旁边配上塞尔吉奥著名的自制莎莎酱。我发现作为演员，你们并不是很喜欢蛋白。哦，还有更多呢。凯特吃蛋白炒蛋配火鸡培根，奥斯卡，出人意料的改变，烤奶酪配番茄，艾米·瑞安，我们本周的嘉宾，菠菜炒蛋。现在，有些演员的早餐订单成了经典，因为它们太受欢迎了。
Okay. Okay. So you could order these three. We've already discussed the Rashida special. Yes. So remember, invented by Rashida, black beans, turkey bacon, avocado, egg whites, Sergio's salsa, two corn tortillas on the side. All right.
好吧。好吧。所以你可以点这三种。我们已经讨论过拉什达特制了。是的。所以记住，由拉什达发明，黑豆、火鸡培根、牛油果、蛋白、塞尔吉奥的莎莎酱，旁边配两张玉米饼。好的。
That's a Rashida. It was the most popular. Okay. The Rashida special. Rashida inventing the most popular process. In fact, it was like one of Mindy's regular orders was the Rashida. Okay. The Johnny K invented by John Krasinski, tomatoes and broccoli with egg whites and a little cheddar
这就是拉什达特制。这是最受欢迎的。好吧。拉什达特制。拉什达发明了最受欢迎的烹饪流程。事实上，明迪的固定点单之一就是拉什达特制。好吧。强尼K特制，由约翰·卡拉辛斯基发明，西红柿和西兰花配蛋白和一点切达奶酪。
cheese. Mmm. That sounds right. I know. Kind of gross. I don't want to eat broccoli first thing in the morning. I don't know. I'm not going to lie.
嗯。听起来不错。我知道。有点恶心。我可不想一大清早就吃西兰花。我不知道。我可不撒谎。
There were, you know, a few times I would cross over here and make up with John. Um, it didn't smell good. It's coming back to me now. Smell good. Okay. The Creed special. I learned something. Creed is apparently a big goat cheese fan.
你知道，我有好几次会去化妆间找约翰。嗯，味道不太好。现在我想起来了。味道很好。好吧。克里德特制。我学到了一点。克里德显然是个山羊奶酪的超级粉丝。
He loves goat cheese in the morning. Oh yeah. And they said that he would have goat cheese, spinach, onions and egg whites with green tea. Oh. Mm-hmm. They also shared the two cast members who were always there the earliest. Oh, let me guess.
他早上超爱山羊奶酪。哦，是的。他们说他会吃山羊奶酪、菠菜、洋葱和蛋白，配一杯绿茶。哦。嗯哼。他们还分享了总是最早到达片场的两名演员。哦，让我猜猜。
Okay. Kate and Phyllis. Leslie and Phyllis. Okay. And you know, I looked at the call sheets, Leslie, Phyllis, me and Kate were always called in at 5 a.m. Mm-hmm. Okay.
好吧。凯特和菲利斯。莱斯利和菲利斯。好吧。你知道，我看过通告单，莱斯利、菲利斯、我和凯特总是被叫到早上5点集合。嗯哼。好吧。
The four of us. I clearly didn't make the early list. But Leslie would order his breakfast at 4.45. Wow. Yeah. Sergio and Alan also did a huge lunch with multiple meat, fish, veggie choices, salad bar, dessert bar. But they said there was one item they featured just on a whim at the dessert table and it
我们四个。我显然没进早到名单。但莱斯利会在4点45分点他的早餐。哇。是的。塞尔吉奥和阿兰还负责丰盛的午餐，有多种肉类、鱼类、素食选择、沙拉吧、甜品吧。但他们说有一个单品是他们在甜品台上突发奇想推出的，结果变得
became incredibly popular. And if they wouldn't have it, people would like get like annoyed. They'd be like, where is it? Can I guess? Yeah. Was it the warm chocolate chip cookie bar? Yes. Yes.
超级受欢迎。如果他们没有做这个，大家就会有点生气。他们会问，东西呢？我能猜猜吗？是的。是温热的巧克力豆曲奇饼干盘吗？是的。是的。
It was the chocolate chip cookie cake. And they served it like hot and melted and kind of gooey. Yeah. Mm-hmm. It was so good. You guys, the chocolate chip cookie cake was Steve Carell's, like Kryptonite. Yes. I don't know.
就是巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕。他们把它加热，融化后有点软糯的那种形式端上来。是的。嗯哼。太好吃了。伙计们，巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕简直就是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的克星。是的。我不知道。
This guy would eat so healthy, but he had to eat this chocolate chip cookie cake. This is one treat. But literally they said they didn't think much about it. They made it one time. And then everyone was like, where is it? Where is it? They had to make it like every day. Yeah.
这家伙平时吃得那么健康，但他就是抗拒不了这个巧克力豆曲奇蛋糕。这是一道点心。但他们字面意思上说，一开始他们没把它当回事。就做了一次。然后每个人都问，在哪儿呢？在哪儿呢？他们不得不每天都做。是的。
So now I have to talk about Peter and Vartan. They were the snack masters. They had kind of like a full kitchen right on the set, right outside the Dunder Mifflin bullpen. Yep. You know, they had a fridge. You could have cereal. They had milk.
所以现在我得聊聊彼得和瓦尔坦了。他们是零食大师。他们就在片场搭了一个差不多是全功能的厨房，就在邓德米夫林办公区外面。没错。你知道，他们有个冰箱。你可以吃麦片。他们有牛奶。
You could make your own sandwich. But they would also have a little food bar. And here's what they had to share. Peter talked about how he had been in the business forever. He also said, I thought this was kind of funny, that our cast, we were tea obsessed. He had hundreds of different types of teas. And you might have noticed that I didn't make Sergio and Alan's breakfast list. Because you would never eat an egg in the morning.
你可以自己做三明治。但他们还会准备一个小食吧。以下是他们分享的内容。彼得谈到他在这个行业干了很久。他还说，我觉得这挺搞笑的，我们剧组的人对茶有着狂热的痴迷。他有上百种不同类型的茶。你可能注意到我没有进入塞尔吉奥和阿兰的早餐名单。因为你早上绝不会吃鸡蛋。
Because Peter and Vartan got donuts every morning. So I would go get a donut from Peter and Vartan. Also BJ liked the Porto's coffee cake. And then Peter said, sometimes he would make you and I sandwiches. He would. And he said he loved doing it and he would put them on a porcelain plate and bring them to us. I'm crying again.
因为彼得和瓦尔坦每天早上都会准备甜甜圈。所以我就会去彼得和瓦尔坦那儿拿一个甜甜圈。另外BJ喜欢波尔图的咖啡蛋糕。然后彼得说，有时候他会给你和我做三明治。他确实会。并且他说他很乐意这么做，而且他会把三明治放在瓷盘里拿给我们。我又哭了。
I know. I know. He took such good care of us. I can't explain to you, like the care with which he would make us a sandwich. It's so silly and simple. But he would. He'd put it on a porcelain plate. And he'd always like garnish it with some cute little like fruit or like a little pickle.
我知道。我知道。他把我们照顾得太好了。我无法向你们解释，他给我们做三明治时所倾注的那种关爱。这听起来很傻很单纯。但他真的会这么做。他会把它放在瓷盘里。而且他总是会用一些可爱的小水果或者小酸黄瓜之类的东西来点缀。
Like he cut fruit into a shape. It really was. It was like your grandpa made you a sandwich. It really was. And you felt so loved. He was so happy to do it. He said that he would make you a tuna fish sandwich and he'd make me ham and cheese. I cried through this commentary, Jenna laughed so hard because Peter and Vartan give each
比如他把水果切成某种形状。真的。就像是你爷爷给你做三明治一样。确实如此。你会觉得自己被深深地爱着。他做这件事时感到非常快乐。他说他会给你做金枪鱼三明治，给我做火腿奶酪三明治。我听这段评论音轨时一直在哭，珍娜则笑得前仰后合，因为彼得和瓦尔坦总是充满爱意地互相抬杠，他们太搞笑了。
other like such a hard time lovingly and they're so funny. Alan called them the Middle Eastern odd couple because Peter is from Greece and Vartan is from Iraq. They had a hilarious banter, the two of them. They also talked about their infamous 10 a.m. hot snack. Hot snack. Oh my gosh. Peter said they like to mix it up every day.
阿兰叫他们中东怪奇组合，因为彼得来自希腊，瓦尔坦来自伊拉克。他们两个人的互动非常搞笑。他们还谈到了他们那臭名昭著的上午10点热小吃。热小吃。噢，天哪。彼得说他们喜欢每天换着花样来。
He said on Mondays, for example, there'd be tacos and burritos. One of the most popular hot snack items was a bandagas soup. Well, they talked about that, but they said they're turkey chili. Oh. They said they're turkey chili. They had to serve twice a week. People wanted it. They loved it.
他说，比如周一，会有墨西哥卷饼和玉米卷。最受欢迎的热小吃之一是班达加斯汤。好吧，他们谈过那个，但他们说那是他们的火鸡辣椒汤。哦。他们说那是他们的火鸡辣椒汤。他们一周得供应两次。大家都想要。他们太喜欢了。
Ed Helms in particular loved the turkey chili and he came up with a little tip. What is it? Ed, you know, they had garnishes on the side for the chili. They had shredded cheese and they had onions. Ed would put the raw onions at the bottom of his bowl, add the hot turkey chili on top and the heat from the chili would caramelize the onions at the bottom. Wow. It became a thing.
尤其是埃德·海尔姆斯，他特别喜欢火鸡辣椒汤，他还想出一个小秘诀。是什么？埃德，你知道的，他们为辣椒汤准备了配菜。有碎奶酪和洋葱。埃德会把生洋葱放在碗底，把热腾腾的火鸡辣椒汤倒在上面，辣椒汤的热量会把底部的洋葱慢慢焦糖化。哇。这成了一种风尚。
So and much like our Dundermifflin counterparts, they said the cast and crew had their favorite pizza places to order from if we went to overtime and we got second meal. Steve loved Mulberry's pizza and we all love Barone's pizza. Yes. It was a delight. You guys, I just have to tell you, we loved these men so much. I was lucky enough to work with Sergio again when I guest starred on Mindy's show, Never Have I Ever.
所以，就像我们在邓德米夫林的同行一样，他们说如果我们要加班吃第二顿饭的话，演员和剧组都有自己最喜欢点外卖的披萨店。史蒂夫喜欢莫尔伯里的披萨，而我们所有人都喜欢巴隆的披萨。是的。这真是一种享受。伙计们，我必须告诉你们，我们太爱这些男士了。我很幸运能再次和塞尔吉奥合作，当时我去客串了明迪的剧《好想做一次》。
She still wants Sergio on her projects. It was so awesome. These guys were our family. Yeah. And they took such good care of us. And if you have ever wondered why the only thing my dad talked about was the food when he visited set. According to this commentary, I loved that.
她现在还想让塞尔吉奥参与她的项目。这太棒了。这些人就像我们的家人一样。是的。他们把我们照顾得无微不至。如果你曾经纳闷为什么我爸爸参观片场时唯一滔滔不绝谈论的就是食物。根据这个评论音轨，我太爱这个了。
I loved it too. And I know I went on and on, but I had to share it. I hope everyone else found it interesting because I loved that trip down memory lane. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. All right. Shall we get into this episode? I guess we can.
我也超爱。我知道我一直在喋喋不休，但我必须分享出来。希望其他人也觉得有趣，因为我太喜欢那段重温美好回忆的旅程了。谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。好了。我们开始讲这一集吗？我想我们可以吧。
I will pull myself together. Yes. This episode starts with Jim and Pam on the phone. Pam is kind of mad because nobody congratulated her on her engagement. And Jim says, yeah, I didn't tell anyone. And then he's like, let's tell him. And he puts Pam on speakerphone and it goes, I think exactly how Jim thought it would go. Yeah.
我会收拾好心情的。好的。这一集以吉姆和潘的电话开始。潘有点生气，因为没有人祝贺她订婚。吉姆说，是的，我没告诉任何人。然后他说，我们告诉他们吧。接着他把潘的免提打开了，事情的发展，我想完全符合吉姆的预期。是的。
It ends with Michael arriving and hearing the news and tackling Jim to the floor. We got a fan question from Kyle T. and Peyton M. How was the stunt done where Michael knocks Jim over with a hug? Also John's face is just amazing. You know, that is a really hard thing to do to know you're going to be tackled, but keep your body relaxed. And not like wits. Yeah.
结局是迈克尔赶到，听到了这个消息，直接把吉姆扑倒在地。我们收到了来自凯尔·T和佩顿·M的粉丝提问。迈克尔用一个拥抱把吉姆撞倒的那个特技是怎么完成的？还有，约翰的表情简直绝了。你知道，要做到明明知道自己要被扑倒，但还要保持身体放松，这真的很难。而且不能表现出刻意防备。是的。
Not expect the tackle. Well, I wasn't there. I was backstage on a phone, so I didn't see it go down. Angela, do you remember? Was there like a mattress or something that they landed on? There is a big blue squishy thing. You know what I mean? A big blue square.
不能预期会被扑倒。好吧，我当时不在。我在后台打电话，所以没看到事发经过。安吉拉，你还记得吗？是不是有什么床垫之类的东西供他们着陆？有一个巨大的蓝色海绵垫。你知道我的意思吗？一个巨大的蓝色正方形垫子。
It looked like a gymnastics kind of map, right? Yeah. But it was so funny. I have to imagine John lost it because John did not do well in scenes like that, especially with Steve Blake. I don't. My memory of it is they didn't do it very many times. Okay.
看起来像那种体操用的垫子，对吧？是的。但太搞笑了。我不得不想象约翰当时肯定笑场了，因为约翰最应付不了这种场景，尤其是和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在一起时。我不。我的记忆是他们没拍很多次。好吧。
Well, now we're into the episode. It's Ethics Day. Holly has passed out of form. Everyone has to fill out. She's going to be taken this seriously. She is. She explains that she is going to be running her first meeting. But don't worry.
好吧，现在我们进入这一集了。今天是道德日。霍莉发下了一张表格。每个人都必须填写。她对此非常认真。确实如此。她解释说这是她主持的第一场会议。不过别担心。
We talked about this with Amy Ryan. She's going to help her out, and they're going to start it off with their version of let's get physical with headbands and dancing and a boom box. Jenna, I worked in corporate America. I have been in human resources seminars that we had to go to. I'm telling you, they had skits. What? When I watched this, I had such a flood of memories coming back of sitting in a tiny little
我们和艾米·瑞安聊过这件事。她会去帮她，他们会以自己的方式开场，比如播放带劲的音乐、戴着头带、跳着舞，还有一个手提音响。珍娜，我曾在美国的企业界工作过。我参加过那种不得不去的人力资源研讨会。我跟你说，他们还演过短剧。什么？当我看到这里时，记忆如潮水般涌来，想起我在这家公司工作时，坐在那个小小的
conference room when I worked at this company. And our human resources department, there were two people. They would come in and act out skits of what's inappropriate. We had one guy. His name was Tom. And we had a gal. Her name was Susan. And he'd be like, Susan, that skirt looks really nice on you today.
会议室里的情景。我们的人力资源部当时有两个人。他们会走进来，通过短剧表演什么是不当行为。我们有个家伙，名字叫汤姆。还有一个女孩，名字叫苏珊。然后他会说，苏珊，你今天穿这件裙子真好看。
Hey, time to party. And then Susan would do a face like, huh? And then they'd freeze. And then Tom would say, what was inappropriate in this moment? And we'd all have to raise our hands and be like, he was kind of gross about her skirt. I only had to watch, like, produced videos of weird things. I've never seen a live presentation. Oh, no.
嘿，是时候开派对啦。然后苏珊会做出一种“啊？”的表情。接着他们就会定格。然后汤姆会说，刚才那一幕有什么不妥之处？然后我们都得举手回答说，他对她裙子的评价有点恶心。我只看过那种拍摄好的、关于奇怪行为的制作视频。我从来没看过现场表演。哦，不。
I watched skits. We had a fan question about this scene from Patricia B. She said, I'm wondering if some of the younger office fans even know the song that Holly and Michael are performing. She wants to know, Angela, did your kids watch this one with you? Do you have to explain the song parody? Isabel watched it with me. She didn't ask about the song. She thought it was funny.
我看过短剧。我们收到了一条来自帕特丽夏·B关于这个场景的粉丝提问。她说，我在想，一些较年轻的办公室粉丝甚至知道霍莉和迈克尔在表演什么歌吗？她想知道，安吉拉，你的孩子有和你一起看这一集吗？你得解释这首歌的滑稽模仿吗？伊莎贝尔和我一起看的。她没有问这首歌的事。她觉得挺好笑的。
She probably thinks we made it up. Yeah, this was, I guess, for our younger listeners, a very famous song by Olivia Newton-John. Let's get physical. And the music video was like her in like an aerobics class singing and dancing with a headband. Jane Fonda had like these workout videos at the time, too. This was like a little trend, sexy working out. But your sexy workout included tights, leg warmers, high tops, leotard, headband wristband.
她可能以为是我们自己编的吧。对，对于我们年轻的听众来说，我想这曾是一首奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰非常著名的歌。《Let's Get Physical》。那部音乐录影带里，她就像是在有氧健身课上，戴着头带边唱边跳。简·方达当时也有这种健身录影带。这在当时算是一种小潮流，也就是性感健身。但你们的性感健身包括紧身裤、护腿袜、高帮鞋、连体衣、头带和护腕。
Yeah, it was a whole thing. It was. I remember it well. Well, Holly begins her ethics meeting by explaining that there's been some misconduct. She's clearly talking about Ryan. Who's been hired again? It's so hilarious to me. I know.
对，这是一整套行头。确实是的。我对此记忆犹新。嗯，霍莉通过解释说发生了一些不当行为来开启她的道德规范会议。她显然是在说瑞安。他居然又被雇用了？这让我觉得太荒谬了。我懂。
And then she starts going through the results of the quiz. Yeah, pretty much. She's got this binder. And she's got to go through the binder. The HR binder. We had a fan question from Peyton M. In the conference room scene, did Creed and Meredith actually break when Stanley said the meeting was a waste of time, or was it scripted for them to laugh?
然后她开始宣读测验结果。对，差不多吧。她拿着一个文件夹。她得把文件夹里的内容念完。那个HR的文件夹。我们有一个来自佩顿·M的粉丝提问。在会议室的那个场景里，当斯坦利说这个会议是在浪费时间时，克里德和梅雷迪思是真的笑场了，还是剧本安排他们笑的？
Well, I looked at the script. It was scripted. The script said, people laugh a lot. That was the direction in the script. So the meeting isn't going so great. And Michael's like, you're losing them. Yeah. She pulls Holly aside.
嗯，我看过剧本。那是剧本安排的。剧本上写着：大家笑得很厉害。剧本里就是这么要求的。所以这个会议进展得不太顺利。然后迈克尔就说，你快镇不住他们了。对。她把霍莉拉到一边。
You are losing them. They expect a lot. Yeah, it's really sweet. He's trying to help her in this meeting because he really wants her to succeed. So he says, let's get rid of the binder. This is your opportunity to speak up without any repercussions. He's like, guys, what are some things maybe you've done at work to waste time? What have you done?
你镇不住他们。他们的期望值很高。对，这真的很贴心。他试图在这场会议中帮她，因为他真心希望她能成功。所以他说，把文件夹扔了吧。这是你们畅所欲言、不用承担任何后果的机会。他就像在说，各位，也许你们在工作中做过哪些浪费时间的事？你们做过什么？
Anything or anything you want to share? Yeah. You have immunity. Go for it. Well, during this time, Michael confesses that he didn't work for five days when he discovered YouTube. He laughed so hard. He said he watched Cookie Monster Sings Chocolate Rain about a thousand times.
有什么想分享的吗？对。你们有豁免权。尽管说吧。嗯，在这期间，迈克尔坦白说，他发现了YouTube之后，有五天没工作。他笑得太厉害了。他说他把《甜饼怪唱巧克力雨》看了大约一千遍。
Did you go watch it? I had to know. Of course. Here's the thing. What? Chocolate Rain, according to its Wikipedia page, was a song by American singer, Tay Zonde. I went and watched Tay's last night. Oh, you did?
你有去看吗？我得去查查看。当然了。事情是这样的。什么？根据维基百科的页面，《巧克力雨》是美国歌手泰·宗达创作的一首歌。我昨晚去看了泰的视频。哦，你看过？
I did. You watched it as well. Yeah. Yes. So he wrote this song and he uploaded a video to YouTube. It was four minutes, 52 seconds long. He uploaded it, everyone, because I know you want to know, April 22, 2007. I remember it went viral.
我看过了。你也看了吧。对。是的。所以他写了这首歌，并把视频上传到了YouTube。它时长四分钟52秒。各位，我知道你们想知道，他是于2007年4月22日上传的。我记得它当时火遍全网。
Viral. Like before things went viral. It was ranked the hottest viral video of summer 2007 and it was awarded the 2008 YouTube Award in the category of music. So this song then became the subject of like parodies, remixes, tributes. It was everywhere. Even Cookie Monster. Not Cookie Monster.
火了。在事情真正病毒式传播之前。它被评为2007年夏天最热门的网络病毒视频，并荣获2008年YouTube音乐类奖项。所以这首歌后来成了各种恶搞、混音和致敬的主题。到处都是。甚至连甜饼怪也有。不是甜饼怪。
We made that up. There was no Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain. They wrote that and after the episode aired, people made them. Oh, no way. I didn't know that. Yes. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy.
那是我们编的。根本没有什么甜饼怪唱《巧克力雨》。那是他们写出来的，而在这一集播出后，人们真的制作了这样的视频。哦，不会吧。我以前不知道。是的。是不是很疯狂？这太疯狂了。
You know, I did go to every version you could imagine of this song. I looked it up and I did notice the one where Cookie Monster is singing it. The first comment said, who else is here because of Michael Scott? Yeah, exactly. Well Michael has opened the door to confession time and people are just letting it fly. Yeah. The big confession comes from Meredith who says that she has been having a six-year affair with the hammer mill rep in exchange for discounts on our supplies and also Outback
你知道吗，我确实去搜了这首歌你能想象到的所有版本。我查了一下，我还真注意到了甜饼怪唱的那一个。第一条评论说：还有谁是因为迈克尔·斯科特才来这里的？没错，正是如此。好吧，迈克尔已经打开了坦白时间的大门，大家也都畅所欲言了。是的。最大的爆料来自梅雷迪思，她说她和锤磨机公司的代表保持了六年的地下情，以此换取我们办公用品的折扣以及奥特牛排馆的礼品券。
Steakhouse gift certificates. Bruce Myers. Bruce Myers and Meredith. Six years. Now, here's something. Wasn't there in that previous episode, we finally landed the hammer mill rep when they went to that big conference and it was only a few, remember? I think there's a little continuity catch here.
布鲁斯·迈尔斯。布鲁斯·迈尔斯和梅雷迪思。六年。现在，有个问题。难道在之前的那一集里，当他们去那个大型会议时，我们才终于签下了锤磨机代表，而那也才过去没多久，记得吗？我觉得这里有点连贯性上的漏洞。
Continuity error. Yeah. So she's been sleeping with him for six years, but we only just landed him like two years ago. I don't know, Meredith. Show Bible. Show Bible. Show Bible, guys.
连贯性错误。是的。所以她和他睡了六年，但我们明明是两年前才签下他的。不知道啊，梅雷迪思。剧集圣经。剧集圣经。剧集圣经，伙计们。
Yeah. Holly is troubled. Oh yeah. Holly is like, this is a serious ethics violation. I have to report this. Jenna, there was one other confession that rattled someone else. What? Ryan made a confession and Kevin is like, what?
是的。霍莉感到很不安。哦，是的。霍莉觉得，这是一次严重的违反道德的行为。我必须举报这件事。珍娜，还有另一个坦白把其他人吓了一跳。什么？瑞安坦白了一件事，凯文听了之后反应是：什么？
This is the beginning of the runner, Sam. Can you play it? Last year, you guys were riding me really hard for the website and I just peeled out my Z3 and I knocked the mirror off somebody's car. I never said a thing. Wait. What? What?
这是山姆那个小支线剧情的开始。你能放一下吗？去年，你们为了网站的事把我逼得太紧了，我一气之下开着我的Z3把别人的车后视镜给撞掉了。我什么也没说。等等。什么？什么？
Kevin's like, what? And then immediately after this conference room scene, Kevin approaches Ryan in the kitchen and confronts him. You knocked the mirror off of my car. Yeah. Isn't that messed up? Yeah. That guy did a lot of things I'm not proud of.
凯文的反应是：什么？紧接着这个会议室场景之后，凯文在厨房找到了瑞安并跟他对质。你撞掉了我车的后视镜。对。是不是挺混蛋的？对。那家伙做了很多让我感到羞耻的事。
Wait. When you say that guy, do you mean you? I mean the guy I used to be. I'm Ryan 2.0 and if it makes you feel any better, that guy did a lot of messed up stuff to me too. No, you mean that you did a lot of messed up stuff to you. Look, I feel you. Two.
等等。当你指“那家伙”的时候，是指你吗？我是指曾经的我。我是2.0版的瑞安，如果这能让你心里好受点的话，那家伙也对我做了很多混蛋事。不，你的意思是说你对自己做了很多混蛋事。听着，我理解。第二版。
Okay? That guy took no responsibility for his actions. But are you going to pay for my mirror? If I have to answer for everything that guy did, I'm never going to move on. It was like $200. We're never going to get what we need from that guy. You know my love of Ryan in this rewatch. And I am so sad that did not make it in the episode, but I am so glad it exists.
好吗？那个家伙对自己的行为不承担任何责任。但你打算为我的车镜买单吗？如果我必须为那个家伙做过的一切承担责任，我永远也无法向前看了。那要大概200美元呢。我们从那个家伙身上永远也得不到我们需要的东西。你知道我在重温时有多喜欢瑞安。我很遗憾那一幕没有剪进正片里，但我很高兴它存在。
I know. I showed it to Sam and Sam was like, I know these people. I know these people. Yeah, that's a good example of Los Angeles. But yeah, so Kevin gets Ryan back by putting his sunglasses, his really nice sunglasses in the toaster oven. Amazing. Melt them.
我懂。我把它给山姆看了，山姆说：我认识这些人。我认识这些人。是的，那是洛杉矶的一个好例子。不过，所以凯文通过把他的太阳镜，他那副非常好的太阳镜塞进烤面包机里来报复瑞安。太绝了。烤化了。
Oh. But that was Kevin 1.0. Yeah, he can't be responsible for what that guy did. That's right. So that was the Ryan Kevin runner that got deleted because we just ran out of time, but I thought it was so great. It's so good. So now we have the scene where Michael and Holly are going to meet privately with Meredith
哦。但那是1.0版的凯文。是的，他可不能为那个家伙做的事负责。没错。所以那是被删掉的瑞安和凯文的支线剧情，因为我们时间不够了，但我真的觉得它太棒了。太精彩了。现在我们来到迈克尔和霍莉私下见梅雷迪思的场景，
to discuss her liaison. Yes. You know, Michael is trying very hard to help Meredith say the things she needs to say to get out of trouble. Yeah. Meredith is not getting it. She's not getting it. At all.
商讨她的不正当关系。是的。你知道，迈克尔在极力帮助梅雷迪思说出她需要说的话，以便摆脱麻烦。是的。梅雷迪思根本没搞懂状况。她没搞懂。完全没有。
And Kate is so funny in this scene. So funny. Well, we do have a classic gym prank. We get a gym prank. Yeah. It's been a bit, and I thought it was so funny. And I can tell that John and Rain were having such a good time just because we know them. You gave John that prop, that stopwatch.
凯特在这场戏里太搞笑了。太搞笑了。好吧，我们确实有一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。我们有一个吉姆的恶作剧。是的。已经有一段时间没整了，我觉得这超级搞笑。而且我能看出来，光凭我们对他们的了解，约翰和雷恩玩得可开心了。你把那个道具，那个秒表给了约翰。
He's loving that stopwatch. He's loving it. Yeah. Dwight had said in the conference room that he doesn't do anything personal at work. He wastes no time. And so Jim's going to show him. He's going to like time every single thing he does. Well, right about now is when we would have gone to see Pam at art school.
他太喜欢那个秒表了。他爱不释手。是的。德怀特在会议室里说过，他在工作时从不处理私事。他一秒钟都不浪费。所以吉姆要向他展示一下。他打算掐准德怀特做的每一件事。好吧，差不多就是这个时候，我们会切到去艺术学校看望帕姆的镜头。
And I'm going to tell you about it. Okay. So Pam and her classmates, they get to class and there's a note on the door, no class today. Canceled. Canceled. So her friends are like, let's go get drinks. And Pam's like, I can't. And her friend, Alex, who was played by Rich Summer, says, what do you have to do?
我会跟你们讲讲这事。好的。所以帕姆和她的同学们去上课，结果门上贴着一张纸条：今天没课。取消了。取消了。所以她的朋友们就说，我们去喝一杯吧。帕姆说，我不行。她的朋友亚历克斯（由里奇·萨默饰演）说，你有什么必须要做的事吗？
You're supposed to be in class right now. We know you don't have plans. So they get her to go to this tiki bar for a little day drinking. And I totally remember shooting this, Angela. We're all drinking out of this big giant volcano bowl. There's a flame. It's on fire. Yeah.
你现在本该在课堂里的。我们知道你没有什么计划。于是他们拉着她去了一家蒂基酒吧，在白天喝起了酒。安吉拉，我完全记得我们当时拍摄这个场景的情景。我们都在用这个巨大无比的火山碗喝酒。里面还有火焰。着火了。是的。
We had to have a safety meeting about it. And in the scene, two of the other art students, they're trying to decode this text message. They're wondering what to text back. Well, it's like a guy, right? So she's like wanting to text a guy back, but not seem like to end to him. You know how you have to write the perfect text back. Exactly. To someone you're into, but you don't want to seem too desperate.
我们还得为此开个安全会议。在这个场景中，其他两个艺术生正在试图破解一条短信。他们在琢磨该回什么内容。嗯，是个男生，对吧？所以她想回一个男生的短信，但又不想显得太上心。你知道怎么才能写出完美的回复短信。没。对你有意思的人，但你又不想显得太绝望。
Well, Pam is spiraling. I said in the other episode that we purposely cast people who would seem younger and hipper than Pam. So she would be this fish out of water in art school. Yeah. Well, she's kind of spiraling about that. And she has this great crazy monologue that she blurts out, Sam, will you play the Pam tiki bar scene for me?
好吧，帕姆有点抓狂了。我在上一集里说过，我们故意选角找那些看起来比帕姆更年轻、更时髦的人。这样她在艺术学校里就会显得像条离水的鱼。是的。好吧，她对此有点情绪崩溃。她脱口而出了一段非常精彩疯狂的独白，山姆，你能把帕姆在蒂基酒吧的那段戏放给我听听吗？
Put a wink at the end. Does that mean something? It means she's a dork. So how do I write back, you know, showing them that I'm also a dork? He knows. Don't ask me. I don't even know what I'm doing here. I'm like way older than you guys.
结尾加个眨眼。那是什么意思？意思是她是个书呆子。所以我该怎么回短信，你知道的，向他们展示我其实也是个书呆子？他知道的。别问我。我甚至不知道我在这里干什么。我比你们大好多。
I mean, like I have a fiance and I had like a 10 year plan and like is graphic design even art? At this point, I thought that I would be married and running my own art company, but I just put like big lol, little lol winky face, oh, okay, I thought that was so interesting. We just got a window into what Pam thought her life would be. She says at this point, she thought she would be married and running her own art company. What does she mean by art company? I don't know.
我的意思是，我有一个未婚夫，我曾有一个十年计划，而且平面设计甚至能算艺术吗？在这个节骨眼上，我本以为自己应该已经结婚并经营着自己的艺术公司了，但我却只是发了类似大笑、小笑、眨眼表情的东西，哦，好吧，我觉得这太有意思了。我们得以窥见帕姆曾以为自己的人生会是什么样。她说在这个阶段，她本以为自己会结婚并经营自己的艺术公司。她所说的艺术公司是什么意思？我不知道。
It sounds like something like a fifth grader, yeah, like someday I'm going to own an art company. Does that mean she sells art supplies? Yeah. What does she mean by that? I don't know. I thought it was so, it was such a window into Pam. I thought.
听起来像是个五年级小学生的想法，对吧，就像“总有一天我要拥有一家艺术公司”。这难道意味着她卖美术用品吗？对。她到底是什么意思？我不知道。我觉得这太……这真是深入了解帕姆内心的一个窗口。我当时觉得。
I did too. And, you know, it goes on to show that she drank the whole volcano herself, basically. Yeah. There are more scenes at this bar. She gets really tipsy, but then she has this really peppy talking head where she says if she were in Scranton right now, she'd be an alcoholic, but she's not. She's in New York, so she's a moody artist. She loves New York.
我也是。而且，你知道的，剧情继续发展，基本上显示她一个人喝光了整个火山碗的酒。是的。酒吧里还有更多戏份。她喝得酩酊大醉，但随后她有一个非常精神抖擞的独白镜头，她说如果她现在在斯克兰顿，她早就成酒鬼了，但她没有。她在纽约，所以她是一个多愁善感的艺术家。她爱纽约。
Yeah. Well, I was really bummed that these scenes got cut because one of the art students, the guy who you hear trying to help the girl with her text message was played by one of my very good friends in real life, John Cabrera. You might know him because he was a long time cast member on Gilmore Girls. He played Brian Fuller. He was the bass player in Lane's Band. So we filmed all of these scenes at Pam's Art School.
是的。嗯，这些场景被删掉了，我真的挺沮丧的，因为其中一个艺术生——那个你听到在帮女孩回短信的男生——是由我在现实生活中的好朋友约翰·卡布雷拉扮演的。你可能认识他，因为他是《吉尔莫女孩》的长期演员。他饰演布赖恩·富勒。他是莱恩乐队里的贝斯手。所以我们在帕姆的艺术学校拍了所有这些场景。
They never made it into an episode. He doesn't even have a credit on IMDB for being on the office because all his scenes got cut, but we had the best time. Jenna, have you ever had a volcano? No. Have you? Once. What?
它们最后都没有剪进正片里。他在IMDB上甚至都没有参演《办公室》的演职员表，因为他所有的戏份都被剪掉了，但我们当时玩得超级开心。珍娜，你喝过火山酒吗？没有。你喝过吗？喝过一次。什么？
Once in my- I thought we made that up. That's a real thing. Is it on fire? Yes. It's- Sam is nodding like how many of you had, Sam. Sorry.
有一次在我的——我以为那是我们编的呢。那是真有其物。着火了吗？是的。那是——山姆在点头，好像在说你们有多少人喝过，山姆。抱歉。
That was the most aggressive I've ever- Yeah. It's a staple of the Tiki Bar. Yeah. I've had one. That's all you'll ever need to have. I had one at a bar in Manhattan Beach for a friend's birthday. We got the volcano because my friend's birthday, we were like 25 years old.
那是我有生以来最具有攻击性的——是的。这是蒂基酒吧的标配。是的。我喝过一次。那绝对是你一生中只需要喝一次的东西。我在曼哈顿海滩的一家酒吧里为一个朋友的生日喝过一次。我们点火山酒是因为我朋友过生日，我们当时大概25岁。
It's a huge, huge bowl. It comes on fire. All these different straws in it. It's usually a mixture of pineapple or grapefruit or lime juice, maple syrup, several different types of rums. I felt real gross the next day. What's so funny is I had Pam's experience. You're just all drinking it.
这是一个巨大无比的碗。端上来的时候还带着火。里面插着各种不同的吸管。通常是菠萝汁、葡萄柚汁或青柠汁、枫糖浆以及几种不同朗姆酒的混合物。第二天我感觉整个人糟糕透了。最搞笑的是，我有过和帕姆一样的经历。大家都在一起喝。
You can't tell who's had more or what because there's all these straws flopping out of it. The photos from this evening are real special. We all decided to see if we could do the splits. Oh. It was one of those nights. I didn't do the splits. No, you do it. I do it.
你根本分不清是谁喝得更多，或者喝了什么，因为里面插满了各种吸管。那天晚上的照片可真是太特别了。我们所有人当时都决定看看自己能不能劈叉。哦。那就是那种夜晚。我可没劈叉。不，你劈了。我劈了。
Volcano guys tread lightly. Am I too old to have this experience? I think so. Damn it. You won't feel good the next day. I missed my chance. I started drinking late in life. I know.
火山酒的勇士们请小心。我是不是老得不适合体验这个了？我想是的。该死。你第二天会难受的。我错过了机会。我年轻时开始喝酒比较晚。我知道。
I really did. I think it's okay that you navigated your life without having the volcano experience. I don't know. I'm having some FOMO. Well, now Michael is going to invite Holly to lunch because it's okay if like two attractive people go to lunch. They work together. They're attractive.
我确实挺晚的。我觉得你没体验过火山酒，人生也照常过得很好，没关系的。不知道。我产生了一些错失恐惧症（FOMO）。好吧，现在迈克尔要邀请霍莉去吃午饭，因为两个有吸引力的人一起吃午饭是没问题的。他们一起工作。他们很有吸引力。
Yes. They can eat lunch. But it's not an official date. And there was a deleted Michael talking head that if it was an official date, Holly would know because it would go like this. No. This is not an official date. When it is an official date, she will be aware of it.
是的。他们可以吃午饭。但这算不上正式的约会。还有一个被删掉的迈克尔的单人独白，如果这是一场正式的约会，霍莉是会知道的，因为流程会是这样的：不。这不是一场正式的约会。当这是一场正式的约会时，她自然会察觉到。
There will be a rose. There will be music and dancing, bottle of red, bottle of white, bottle of water. I drink more water, some whispered conversation, some kickling, little wine. We head back to her place. I will skip ahead to protect our dignity. But we make hardcore love. And then we fall asleep on her lani to the sound of the full moon. And then chocolate chip pancakes.
会有一朵玫瑰。会有音乐和舞蹈，一瓶红葡萄酒，一瓶白葡萄酒，一瓶矿泉水。我喝水更多一些，还有一些耳语交谈，一些咯咯的笑声，一点点红酒。我们前往她的住处。为了维护我们的尊严，我将跳过这段。但我们会进行深度的肉体之爱。然后在满月的伴奏声中在她的凉台上入睡。接着是巧克力豆煎饼。
Okay. I haven't had a volcano, but I've had that date. You've had that date. I've had that date. That's a good date. I just want a shirt that says hardcore love. And you know what? You got to fall asleep to the sound of the moon.
好吧。我没喝过火山酒，但我有过那种约会。你经历过那种约会。我有过那种约会。那是个好约会。我只想要一件印着“深度肉体之爱”字样的衬衫。你知道吗？你得伴着月光的声音入睡。
You do. You do. Oh, well, he suggests that they go to Cooper's restaurant and I've got some good information to share about that. So why don't we take a break and we'll come back? Great. All right, we are back. Michael and Holly have gone to lunch.
确实得这样。哦，好吧，他建议他们去库珀餐厅，我有些关于那家餐厅的好消息要分享。那我们为什么不休息一下再回来呢？太好了。好的，我们回来了。迈克尔和霍莉已经去吃午饭了。
We got fan questions from Kelly W, Sammy B, and Carolyn P. What is the restaurant that Holly and Michael went to? Angela, you saw the outside shot of this restaurant. Yeah, I've been there in real life. It is a real restaurant in Scranton called Cooper's Seafood House. And we did not go to Cooper's. So we used a shot of the outside. The interior, I got all the scoop from James Apedia.
我们收到了来自凯利·W、萨米·B和卡洛琳·P的粉丝提问。霍莉和迈克尔去的餐厅叫什么名字？安吉拉，你看到了这家餐厅的外景镜头。是的，我在现实生活中去过那里。那是斯克兰顿一家真实的餐厅，名叫库珀海鲜屋（Cooper's Seafood House）。我们当时并没有去库珀餐厅。所以我们用了外景镜头。至于内景，我从詹姆斯·阿佩迪亚那里打听到了所有的独家内幕。
James Apedia is back. And Amy Ryan said they did an amazing job. Amazing, right? I looked at pictures online of the real Cooper's and I compared them to screenshots because that's what I do now, I guess, is that. And we really, congratulations to our set designers. They did a great job redressing this. What did James Apedia have?
詹姆斯·阿佩迪亚又回来了。艾米·瑞安说他们做得太棒了。太棒了，对吧？我在网上看了真的库珀餐厅的照片，并将它们与截屏进行了对比，因为我现在大概就是会做这种事的人。我们真的，要祝贺我们的布景设计师。他们把内景重新布置得太棒了。詹姆斯·阿佩迪亚都透露了什么？
James Apedia said that we shot the interior at Clancy's Crab Broiler in Glendale, California. That we started shooting at 8 a.m. that day and there was a note on the call sheet that said the restaurant will be open for business at 11 a.m. So they had three hours to film all of those restaurant scenes. And I asked him, I said, now when it says they're going to open back up at 11 a.m., does that mean we have to be done filming and get all our stuff out because we changed the look of the restaurant? And he said, what we would normally do is we would get in there really, really early
詹姆斯·阿佩迪亚说，我们在加利福尼亚州格伦代尔的克兰西蟹肉料理餐厅（Clancy's Crab Broiler）拍摄了内景。我们那天早上8点开始拍摄，通告单上有一条备注，上面写着餐厅将在上午11点开始营业。所以他们只有三个小时来拍摄所有的餐厅场景。我问他，我说，那当上面说他们要在上午11点重新营业时，是不是意味着我们必须结束拍摄并把我们所有的东西都搬出去，因为我们要改变餐厅的外观？他说，我们通常会做的是，我们会非常非常早地进去，
and dress it, do our scenes, and get out as much as we can by 11 o'clock, but they would go back the next day to do a full cleanup. So the patrons that day ate in a kind of hybrid restaurant of Clancy's Crab Broiler slash Cooper's Seafood. Say that 10 times fast. I could barely say it. Clancy's one. Crab Broiler.
布置好现场，拍完我们的戏，然后在11点前尽可能把东西都搬出来，但他们第二天会回去做全面的清理工作。所以那天的顾客是在一种混合餐厅里吃饭，既有克兰西蟹肉料理餐厅的影子，又带点库珀海鲜屋的味道。快速把这句话说十遍。我几乎都说不利落。克兰西。蟹肉料理。
Crab Broiler. Clancy's Crab Broiler. Oof. Well, here's a little something about Cooper's. All right. So Brian Baumgartner and I went there in 2007 in Scranton. If you go to Cooper's Seafood House website online, there are a bunch of photos in their gallery section of Brian and I.
蟹肉料理。克兰西蟹肉料理。呜。好吧，关于库珀餐厅还有这么个小插曲。好吧。布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳和我在2007年去过斯克兰顿的那家店。如果你上网访问库珀海鲜屋的网站，在他们的图库部分有很多我和布赖恩的照片。
I saw them. One in particular, I am barefoot and standing on top of a table. Oh, I missed that one. It's a good one. I'll put it in our stories. Clearly Brian and I were there to have a good time. And we did. We had a blast.
我看到了。其中有一张特别经典，我光着脚站在桌子上。哦，我漏掉那张了。那张很棒。我会把它发到我们的故事（Stories）里。显然我和布赖恩当时去那里就是为了玩得开心。我们确实也玩得很开心。我们嗨翻了天。
Well, this scene originally started with Michael ordering for he and Holly. Yes. He was going to be a fancy man on a date. He said this restaurant was business romantic. Here's what he ordered. We'll have the chowders to start. Then the lobster feast for two. And do you have a house red?
嗯，这个场景最初是以迈克尔为他和霍莉点菜开始的。是的。他要在约会时表现得像个有品位的绅士。他说这家餐厅兼具商务与浪漫。这是他点的菜。我们先来份周打汤。然后是双人龙虾大餐。请问你们有招牌红葡萄酒吗？
And then he wants you to know, house makes a great red. Yes. I feel like, where did he come up with that? He heard that somewhere. Someone was like, the house wine is very good. The house makes a great red. And now he's like, he thinks the house is the winery. Yes.
然后他想让你知道，他们店里自己酿的红酒非常棒。是的。我就觉得，他这是从哪听来的？他肯定在哪听过别人这么说。有人说：他们家的自酿酒非常好。他们家酿的红酒很棒。然后现在他就觉得“他们家”指的是某个酿酒庄园。是的。
Well, Holly says she just wants a chef's salad. No dressing. With an iced tea. Yes. She's not going to have any house red. And then the waitress says to Michael, do you still want the two lobsters? And Michael says, yes, yes, I do, because now he's a little embarrassed. So later in the scene, when you see Michael and he's got two lobsters and a big bowl
好吧，霍莉说她只要一份主厨沙拉。不要沙拉酱。还要一杯冰茶。是的。她才不要什么招牌红葡萄酒。然后女服务员问迈克尔：你还要两只龙虾吗？迈克尔说：要的，要的，我要的，因为现在他觉得有点不好意思了。所以在这个场景的后面，当你看到迈克尔时，他面前有两只龙虾、一大碗汤和一杯红葡萄酒。这就是原因。是的。
of soup and a red wine. This is why. Yes. It's at 13 minutes 44 seconds. You'll see how he ordered double. Incidentally, on the Cooper's menu, there is a recurring Tuesday special called Twin Tails and a Cup of Soup. And it is two lobster tails and a bread bowl of soup.
在13分44秒的时候。你会看到他是怎么点成双份的。顺便说一句，在库珀餐厅的菜单上，有一个每周二固定的特色菜，叫做“双尾加一杯汤”。里面是两只龙虾尾和一个面包碗装的汤。我特别想知道，这个周二特色菜是在《办公室》这一集播出之前就有了，还是在迈克尔点了两只龙虾尾和一碗汤之后他们才专门推出了这道特色菜。我不知道该怎么去查证。
And I am dying to know if this Tuesday special predated this episode of the office or if they created this as a special after Michael ordered two lobster tails and a bowl of soup. I don't know how to find out. Well, we'll have to go. Anyone, Cooper's, anyone. Yeah. Well, here's the thing. We are going to Scranton.
好吧，我们得去一趟了。不管是库珀餐厅的谁，随便谁都行。是的。嗯，事情是这样的。我们要去斯克兰顿了。
We are. I can't wait. Should we order two lobster tails and a bowl of soup and a house red? Yes. We're going to do so much eating in Scranton. I know. Like the bulk of our trip there is just eating our way through Scranton. I know.
我们要去了。我简直等不及了。我们是不是应该点两只龙虾尾、一碗汤和一杯自酿红酒？是的。我们在斯克兰顿要吃好多东西。我知道。就像我们在那里的主要行程就是一路吃遍斯克兰顿。我知道。
Well, this lunch, it just is not going well. They cannot get on the same page about what to do with Meredith. They can't. Michael was trying to just connect with Holly, get to know her. He asked her, you know, about where she grew up, Des Moines. We find out she's from Des Moines, Iowa, right? Holly is being business. This is a business lunch and she feels gross about Meredith.
好吧，这顿午饭进行得非常不顺利。关于怎么处理梅雷迪思，他们俩完全达不成共识。根本谈不拢。迈克尔本想借此机会跟霍莉拉近距离，多了解她一些。他问了她关于她成长的地方——得梅因。我们发现她是来自爱荷华州得梅因的，对吧？霍莉现在是一副公事公办的态度。这是一场商务午餐，而且她觉得梅雷迪思的事让人感到很恶心。
They have this couplet of dialogue that really sums it up. Holly says, I'm saying that Meredith's behavior is unethical and a little icky. And I don't think I want to work in an environment where that sort of conduct is tolerated. Michael says, well, you have to tolerate a lot when you're part of a family. And Holly delivers such a low blow. If you know Michael, she says, it's not a family. It's a workplace. Oh my gosh, the look on his face.
他们有一段对话完美地总结了这一点。霍莉说：“我说梅雷迪思的行为不仅违背职业道德，而且有点恶心。我不想在一个容忍这种行为的环境里工作。”迈克尔说：“嗯，当你成为一个大家庭的一员时，你必须包容很多东西。”而霍莉则说出了一句杀伤力极大的话。如果你了解迈克尔的话，就会知道她的话有多伤人。她说：“这不是一个家庭。这是一个工作场所。”哦天哪，他脸上的表情。
Like, how do they come back from this? Meanwhile, back at the office, Jim is really trying to trap Dwight into wasting time. He's trying to get him to have personal conversations. He tries to explain an episode of Battlestar Galactica to Andy, purposely getting everything wrong and inserting all kinds of other characters. All kinds of other characters. He says it's like the crazy monsters and stuff. There's Klingons and Wookies.
那表情就像是：他们这要怎么收场啊？与此同时，办公室里，吉姆正在绞尽脑汁地设陷阱让德怀特浪费时间。他试图引诱德怀特和自己进行私人谈话。他试图向安迪解释一集《太空堡垒卡狄加》，故意把所有情节都搞得一团糟，还塞进去了各种其他角色的设定。各种乱七八糟的角色。他说里面有疯狂的怪兽之类的内容。里面有克林贡人和楚巴卡。
He says there's a guy named Dumbledore. They're trying to get a ring back to Mordor. This is triggering every button in Dwight. I loved Rain in the scene, where he just was. And I also just loved the way John would hold up the stopwatch. Oh yeah, they were doing this beautiful, like, comedic dance. It was so good. It was so good.
他说里面有一个叫邓布利多的人。他们正试图把一枚戒指送回末日火山。这直接踩中了德怀特所有的雷区。我太喜欢雷恩在这个场景里的表现了，他当时那个样子。而且我也超喜欢约翰举起秒表的样子。哦是的，他们当时在跳着一支优美迷人的喜剧舞蹈。太棒了。太精彩了。
You know, we had a fan point out, Lindsay H said, I am so impressed with the camera focus when Jim is talking to Andy about Battlestar Galactica slash Star Wars slash Harry Potter slash Lord of the Rings slash Star Wars. Anyway, she says the camera focuses on Jim, then Dwight and back and forth so quickly and flawlessly. She just wanted to give kudos to our camera operators. Yeah. Yeah, because, I mean, John and Rain are doing this dance, but they're in it with the camera
你知道的，有粉丝指出——林赛·H说：当吉姆和安迪谈论《太空堡垒卡狄加》混搭《星球大战》混搭《哈利·波特》混搭《指环王》混搭《星球大战》时，摄像机的对焦速度让我叹为观止。总之，她说镜头在吉姆和德怀特之间来回切换，既迅速又完美无瑕。她只是想向我们的摄像师致敬。对。是的，因为，我是说，约翰和雷恩在跳这段舞，但他们是和摄像师一起融入其中的，而且配合得天衣无缝。我赞同你的看法，林赛。
operator and that was flawless. I agree, Lindsay. Me too. We also had a fan catch from Justin S. Jenna, I know you. And Phyllis are both from St. Louis, and I'm a big Cardinals fan myself, and I couldn't help but notice that there is a free bird on Phyllis's desk over Dwight's shoulder. And I was just wondering, how did the free bird get there? Guys, I texted Phyllis about it.
我也是。我们还收到了来自贾斯汀·S的粉丝提问。珍娜，我认识你。你和菲利斯都来自圣路易斯，我自己也是个狂热的红雀队球迷，我忍不住注意到在德怀特肩膀后方的菲利斯桌上有一只自由鸟。我只是想知道，那只自由鸟是怎么到那儿去的？伙计们，为此我给菲利斯发了短信。
Yeah? We don't know. She said, oh, maybe that was when David Fries and Matt Holiday came to visit. And I was like, no, they haven't come to visit yet. I'll tell you guys that story later. That was amazing. You guys were so excited. And I know they hadn't visited yet because Ellie was with us when they visited.
是吗？我们也不知道。她说：“哦，也许那是大卫·弗里斯和马特·霍利迪来参观的时候留下的吧。”然后我说：“不对，他们还没来参观呢。”回头我再跟你们讲那个故事。那太棒了。你们当时可兴奋了。而且我知道他们还没参观，因为他们来的时候艾莉跟我们在一起。
So Phyllis and I went back and forth, and she's like, I didn't bring it in. She said, I don't know who put it there. I didn't put it there. Phyllis didn't put it there. We don't know who put it there. Well, Justin, I'm sorry. I'm going to try to get to the bottom of it, you know? Answer pending.
所以我和菲利斯反复确认过，她说：“不是我拿进来的。”她说：“我不知道是谁放在那儿的。反正不是我放的。”菲利斯没放过那东西。我们不知道是谁放的。好吧，贾斯汀，我很抱歉。我会试着查明真相的，好吗？答案待揭晓。
Yeah. Jim has a talking head that Dwight hasn't stopped working for a second. He even sneezed with his eyes open, which Jim was like, I didn't know that was possible. You guys, he peed in a soda bottle. He peed under his desk. I mean, he is not going to waste any time. I had to know if you can sneeze with your eyes open. You can't.
是的。吉姆有个单人独白，说德怀特一秒钟都没停止工作。他甚至连打喷嚏时眼睛都是睁开的，吉姆当时就觉得：我以前都不知道这居然有可能。伙计们，他在苏打水瓶里小便。他在办公桌底下撒尿。我是说，他是绝对不会浪费一秒钟的。我当时非得弄明白人打喷嚏时到底能不能睁着眼睛。根本不能。
You can. What? Yeah. Mythbusters did a whole story on it. Mythbusters. And I watched it late last night when I suddenly had to know. Yeah. We both went on two random tangents.
可以的。什么？对。流言终结者（Mythbusters）专门做过一期节目讲这个。流言终结者。而且我昨晚很晚的时候查了，因为我突然非得知道不可。是的。我们俩各自陷入了两个毫无关联的胡思乱想中。
Just wait for mine. Is yours about the average amount of time someone has sex? Because I went on that tangent too. Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh. Yes. Okay.
等下听听我的。你的问题是不是关于人们做爱的平均时长？因为我也去查了这个。是的。是的。哦天哪。是的。好吧。
Because there's all of a sudden Dwight is like, not wasting time, not wasting time. And then he comes back and Jim is like, 19 minutes and 48 seconds. What were you up to? And Dwight is like, none of your business, basically. And then it cuts to Angela Martin buttoning her blouse. Did you read the research on Business Insider? I read several articles at like midnight last night. Me too.
因为德怀特突然一会儿说“不浪费时间”，一会儿又说“不浪费时间”。然后他回来了，吉姆就说：19分48秒。你刚刚去干嘛了？德怀特基本上回了一句：关你屁事。然后画面就切到了安吉拉·马丁在系衬衫纽扣。你看过《商业内幕》（Business Insider）上的那份研究报告吗？我昨晚差不多半夜看了好几篇文章。我也是。
On this subject. Our search history. Oh my god. To lead our search history. First of all, the one research I read about was fascinating because they gave 500 couples. Yes. Stopwatches. It is as awkward as it sounds.
关于这个话题的。我们的搜索记录。哦天哪。真是不堪入目的搜索记录。首先，我读到的那项研究非常引人入胜，因为他们找了500对情侣。是的。给他们发了秒表。这听起来有多尴尬，实际就有多尴尬。
They had to hit start and stop. I don't know how we talk about this, but maybe parents, if you're listening with your kids earmuffs for 30 seconds, earmuffs. Yeah. They had to record their sex time over a four week period. Yeah. And they had to press start on the stopwatch at the moment of penetration. Oh god.
他们必须按下开始和停止键。我不知道该怎么谈论这个，但也许各位父母，如果你们正和孩子一起听播客的话，请把孩子的耳朵捂上30秒，捂上耳朵。是的。他们必须在四周的时间里记录他们的做爱时间。是的。而且他们必须在进入的那一刻按下秒表上的开始键。哦天哪。
And they had to press stop at ejaculation. We read the same article. Oh my god. You know what? I found amazing is the range was from 33 seconds to 44 minutes. Yeah. That's a huge, huge variation. It is.
然后他们必须在射精时按下停止键。我们读的是同一篇文章。哦天哪。你知道吗？我觉得最惊人的地方在于，时间范围从33秒到44分钟不等。是的。这是一个巨大、巨大的差异。确实如此。
And then what was really interesting to me was I read this whole article by a sex therapist who after doing a bunch of research broke down the ideal amount of penetration time in a sex act. I mean, this is insane. I told Lee all last night everything I'd read. He's like, how are you sharing this on office ladies? I was like, I don't know, but I found it so fascinating. I know.
然后让我觉得真正有趣的是，我读了一位性治疗师写的整篇文章，她在做了大量研究后，细分出了性行为中理想的进入时长。我的天，这太疯狂了。我昨晚把我读到的所有内容都告诉了李。他说：你怎么能在《办公室女士》里分享这些？我说：我也不知道，但我真的觉得太迷人了。我知道。
So what she found was that in surveying the person being penetrated, that their ideal amount of penetration time in sex was anywhere from five to 11 minutes. But all of sex, they all wanted more than just penetration. So she deemed that the ideal amount of sex encompassing more than just that moment would be around 19 minutes and that it should consist of 10 minutes of foreplay and nine minutes of actual intercourse that she felt this was the bullseye after all of her research. Well, something I discovered in my research is that of these 500 couples surveyed, the average time was 5.4 minutes.
所以她的发现是，在对被进入的那一方进行调查时，他们认为在性爱中理想的进入时长大约是5到11分钟。但对于完整的性爱过程，他们想要的不仅仅是进入。所以她认为，包含比单纯那一刻更多内容的理想性爱时长应该在19分钟左右，其中应该包括10分钟的前戏和9分钟的实际性交，她经过所有的研究后认为这才是完美的靶心。好吧，我在研究中发现的一点是，在受调查的这500对情侣中，平均时间是5.4分钟。
And this was true across continents. I mean, literally, it's a global thing. And this got me to thinking, 19 minutes and 48 seconds. Yeah. I did the math. I think it took them six minutes to get down to the warehouse, six minutes to walk down a set of stairs or take the elevator. It's not close.
而且跨越不同大洲都是如此。我是说，字面意义上讲，这是个全球现象。这让我开始思考：19分48秒。是的。我算了一下。我认为他们花了6分钟走到仓库，花了6分钟走下一段楼梯或乘电梯。这可不近。
They have to go in the elevator or stairs and they have to go down the corridor through the warehouse to that back room, open it up. All right. So six minutes to get there, they need six minutes back. That leaves them six minutes in the middle. I think they had six minutes to shag. I mean, I think what we've discovered in all our research is you can have a really satisfying shag in six minutes.
他们必须坐电梯或走楼梯，然后穿过走廊经过仓库来到那个后面的房间，把门打开。好吧。所以花6分钟走到那儿，他们还需要6分钟走回来。中间只剩下6分钟了。我觉得他们有6分钟的时间来翻云覆雨。我的天，我觉得我们在所有的研究中发现的一点是，你完全可以在6分钟内来一次非常令人满足的亲热。
By the way, this article went on to the evolution of sex. Why is there thrusting? It was fascinating. I was fascinated. Oh, the things we have learned and shared with you all. So you're welcome. Well let's get back to this Michael Holly story, okay? This whole lunch has really strained things between Michael and Holly.
顺便说一句，那篇文章还探讨了性爱的进化。为什么会有活塞运动？太吸引人了。我当时看呆了。哦，我们从中学到了这些知识并分享给了大家。所以不客气。好吧，让我们回到迈克尔和霍莉的故事上来，好吗？整顿午饭让迈克尔和霍莉之间的关系变得非常紧张。
When he gets back, he has a talking head where he says he won't even ride the elevator with her. And then he throws her leftovers in the trash. Yeah. And then up in the kitchen, he's pouring himself some coffee. She puts her cup out. Not only does he not pour coffee in her cup, he takes the whole pot and walks out of the kitchen.
等他回来后，他有一个单人独白，说他甚至不肯和她同乘一部电梯。然后他把她的剩饭剩菜直接扔进了垃圾桶。是的。接着在楼上的厨房里，他给自己倒咖啡。她把杯子递了过去。他不仅没有往她的杯子里倒咖啡，反而端起整壶咖啡直接走出了厨房。
She called Dundermifflin a workplace and it is his family and you do not do that. You do not. If Holly wants to use the copier now, she's going to have to wait for Michael to copy a plaque off the wall first. Yeah. Well, Holly has a talking head, things are tense, people are suspicious of her. Her best friend in the office won't even speak to her. So now we have a little window into Holly.
她把邓迪米夫林（Dundermifflin）称作一个工作场所，而这里对迈克尔来说是他的家，你绝对不能那样说。绝对不能。如果霍莉现在想用复印机，她必须先等迈克尔复印完墙上的一块牌匾才行。是的。好吧，霍莉有一个单人独白，气氛很紧张，大家都对她产生怀疑。她在办公室里最好的朋友甚至都不跟她说话了。所以现在我们得以窥见霍莉的内心。
She really sees Michael as her best friend. Now, Angela, in the script, there was a scene here where Michael calls Toby. Yes. For help with Holly. Yes. It's in the deleted scenes. Oh, guys. It's so good because Toby basically says at the end of all of this, oh, well, Michael,
她真的是把迈克尔当成了自己最好的朋友。安吉拉，在剧本里，这里本来有一个场景是迈克尔给托比打电话。是的。寻求关于霍莉的帮助。是的。这在被删减片段里。哦，伙计们。这太绝了，因为托比在这一切的最后基本上说：哦，好吧，迈克尔，
I think Holly's doing the right thing and in fact, now that you've told me, I'm obligated to report this Meredith incident to HR as well. Yeah. But that's how desperate Michael is. Is he's going to call Toby, who I guess is still in a hospital in Costa Rica? And he's still not nice to him. He calls Toby for help, but he's still not nice. This is not the last HR rep that's going to be involved.
我觉得霍莉做得对，事实上，既然你已经告诉我了，我也只好把梅雷迪思这起事件向人力资源部进行汇报。是的。但迈克尔当时绝望到了这种地步。他居然给托比打电话，我猜托比当时还在哥斯达黎加的医院里吧？而且他对他还是很不客气。他打电话向托比求助，但态度依然很差。这可不是最后一个卷入此事的人力资源代表。
Kendall from corporate has called. Holly's going to come in Michael's office and they're going to discuss it with Kendall. Yeah. We had a fan question from Megan Q. Who voices Kendall from corporate HR? Kendall was played by John Hartman. Now the role of Kendall was first mentioned in the episode, The Job. When David Wallace mentions his dislike for the HR rep Kendall during Jim's job interview in New York.
总部的肯德尔打电话来了。霍莉要走进迈克尔的办公室，他们要和肯德尔一起讨论这件事。是的。我们收到了来自梅根·Q的粉丝提问。是谁为总部HR的肯德尔配音的？肯德尔是由约翰·哈特曼（John Hartman）扮演的。而肯德尔这个角色最早是在《工作》那一集里被提及的。
Wow. That's a really good callback. I know, but we also brought him up again in weight loss, I guess. And here's the thing. Kendall is going to come back two more times this season. He comes back in person in stress relief and company picnic. He's always played by John Hartman. You might recognize John.
当时大卫·华莱士在纽约吉姆的求职面试中提到了他对HR代表肯德尔的不满。哇。这真是一个非常棒的前后呼应。我懂，但我想我们在《减肥》那一集里也再次提到了他。事情是这样的。肯德尔这一季还要回来两次。他在《压力缓解》和《公司野餐》里真人出场了。他一直都是由约翰·哈特曼扮演的。你可能认得约翰。
He had roles in Mad Men, Arrested Development, The Good Place, Black-ish, Space Force and Monk. Ah! There it is. Of course. There it is. I think Kendall is going to get Holly's back, right, and agree with her. But instead, he just shuts her down, says he doesn't really see this as a huge infraction,
他在《广告狂人》、《发展受阻》、《善地》、《黑人当道》、《太空部队》和《神探阿蒙》里都演过角色。啊！原来是他。当然了。原来是他。我想肯德尔会支持霍莉，对吧，并同意她的看法。但相反的是，他只是把她压了下去，说他并不认为这是一次多么严重的违规行为，
and what she needed to do was to get everyone through that binder. That was her job. Yeah. We just needed you to get signatures. Are you able to get signatures or not? Because every other branch got signatures. And I think Michael feels badly for her in this moment. I feel badly for her.
而她需要做的是让每个人都过完那个文件夹的流程。那才是她的工作。是的。我们只需要你收集到签字就行了。你到底能不能收集到签字？因为其他所有分公司都收集到签字了。我觉得迈克尔在这个时刻为她感到难过。我也为她感到难过。
I do too. They're doing the right thing, and corporate doesn't have her back. So Holly is just going to go out to the bullpen and say, hey guys, I have to finish this ethics training. She has to finish reading from the binder so she can say she did it. No one is giving her any respect. Well, Michael's going to step up. Because he does feel bad for her.
我也是。他们做的是正确的事，而总部却不支持她。所以霍莉只好走到办公区说：嘿，各位，我必须完成这个职业道德培训。她必须把文件夹里的内容读完，这样她才能说自己完成了任务。没有人给她应有的尊重。好吧，迈克尔要挺身而出了。因为他确实为她感到难过。
So he goes out there and he goes up, you don't get it, you don't get it. He loses it. It's so funny. He goes in, she reads from the binder, and the look on Michael's face as she's like reading from the boring binder. He's in love again. Well, I don't think he ever fell out of love. They had their first spat.
所以他走了出去，然后走过去说：你们根本不懂，你们根本不懂。他情绪失控了。太搞笑了。他走了进去，她开始朗读文件夹的内容，而迈克尔看着她朗读那个枯燥的文件夹时，脸上的表情分明是：他又坠入爱河了。好吧，我觉得他从来就没不爱过。他们只是吵了第一架。
I guess they did. Yeah. Because Holly looks appreciative. They're both like, oh, OK, we're back. We're going to get through this. At the very end of this episode, we have a tag. Everyone's in the break room. They're eating steak that was clearly provided by Meredith.
我想是的。是的。因为霍莉看起来很感激。他们俩都露出了“哦，好吧，我们和好了，我们能度过这一关”的表情。在这集的最后，我们有一个彩蛋。大家都在休息室里。他们在吃牛排，很显然那是梅雷迪思提供的。
We had a fan question from Kelly W. OK, Kelly, what is it? During the last scene when everyone's eating steak in the break room, what is everyone actually eating? Is it prop food or actually real expensive steak? And Savie A. wants to know, Angela, what were you eating since your character is a vegetarian? I was eating potatoes. That's what it looked like to me.
我们收到了来自凯利·W的粉丝提问。好吧，凯利，什么问题？在最后那个大家都在休息室吃牛排的场景里，大家实际吃的是什么？是道具食物，还是真正的昂贵牛排？萨维·A想知道，安吉拉，既然你的角色是个素食主义者，你当时吃的是什么？我吃的是土豆。看起来就是那样。
I was eating potatoes. That's something we thought about. One of the things that Peter and Vartan shared is that our prop food was amazingly good food. That they didn't give us kind of crappy food to eat in scenes. And Peter and Vartan would work with props, but I would have to think that Phil Shea and his team got us really good food from a restaurant. That was going to be my guess. Whenever I ate food in the scene, it was delicious.
我当时在吃土豆。这是我们考虑过的事情之一。彼得和瓦尔坦分享过的一点是，我们的道具食物是好得惊人的食物。他们在拍摄场景时不会给我们吃那种劣质食物。彼得和瓦尔坦会处理道具，但我猜菲尔·谢伊和他的团队一定是从某家餐厅给我们弄来了非常好的食物。我猜也是这样。每当我在场景里吃东西时，都觉得美味极了。
So it was probably some really good steak. What a day at work. Hey, guys, come in and eat these steak and ribs for an hour. Angela, you can have these potatoes. Sorry, Ange. Well, there you have it. That's business ethics. Yeah.
所以那可能真的是某种非常优质的牛排。多么美好的一天啊。嘿，伙计们，进来吃一个小时的牛排和排骨吧。安吉拉，你可以吃这些土豆。抱歉啦，安吉。好吧，事情就是这样。这就是商业道德。是的。
Thank you so much to Amy Ryan. And thank you to James O'Carrie for giving me the lowdown on Coopers. And thank you to BJ Novak for pitching Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Ellen to do the DVD commentary. That was just so wonderful. If you guys love the show, you'll love these commentaries. Well, I think on that note, you might go have a volcano. And I hope all of you guys have some hardcore love in your life for approximately 19 minutes
非常感谢艾米·瑞安。也谢谢詹姆斯·奥凯里向我透露库珀餐厅的内幕。谢谢B·J·诺瓦克邀请彼得、瓦尔坦、塞尔吉奥和埃伦来录制DVD评论音轨。这真的太棒了。如果你们喜欢这部剧，你们一定会喜欢这些评论音轨的。好吧，鉴于此，你们大概想去喝一杯火山酒了。我希望你们所有人在生活中都能体验到大约19分钟，
or an average of six minutes. That would be fine. See you next week. Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin.
或者平均6分钟的深度肉体之爱。那就挺好的。我们下周见。拜拜，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。如需收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。